[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
round eight of the summer classic here
in st. Louis the challengers section
could have been decided a day early as
Camille dragons to rooks on the seventh
was too much for his opponent however
Andres took open retained an outlying
chance of winning first place late in
the round the master section is a
three-horse race after Massif Dhirubhai
Lee was saddled with his first loss
allowing Barra Cobian to tie him at the
top after bars draw with Samsa beyond
the 17 year old is a half-point back
from the lead with playoffs
a possibility there must be a winner
coverage of the final round starts now
twenty international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as us chess champs
calm presents the first ever summer
chess classic
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the st. Lucia
scoffs to do and the 2018 summer chess
classic I am women grillmaster Catriona
me Java and I'm joined by international
master Eric Rosen today we have round
nine the very last round of these two
very strong events so before we look at
how those grow stronger and masters are
playing their games
let's review yesterday's results yeah we
had two decisive games in group a
yesterday with euros Arabic defeating
the tournament leader of a thief Tara
Bailey and Jeffrey Zhang defeating
Alexander and judge so let's take a look
at the standings and see who's in
contention for first place we have two
players tied for first going into this
round the sea star Bailey and version of
Cobian with a very impressive five and a
half out of eight points and we have Sam
Sevilla and right behind with five out
of eight points and let's take a look at
the results for Group B we get to
undecisive results otherwise dinara
sadaqa so I won a very nice game against
sir game I think oh come out dragon the
leader of the term and one against
Alejandro Ramirez that F Abraham iam
lost to Andres to coping and then we had
to draw between Josh free Dell and JJ
Alima Randy and Robert are kesariya and
Vladimir bellows this brings us to
standings and we see that camel dragon
has six points he was followed by Andrus
to copyin who had a chance to catch him
but we have to know that a camel dragon
is the clear winner now congratulations
because average took up Andrew his game
what a nice fireworks here yeah very
good tournament for Camille played some
very high quality chess and deservedly
wins the $4,000 first-place prize so a
huge congratulations Camille but he's
still playing his game so we'll have to
keep an eye on that and see if you can
finish throwing so let's move on to do
tournament format we have 210
round-robin player round robins games
time control is 90 minutes for 40 bucks
plus 30 minutes for the remainder of
their game with a 30 second increment
for a move on and we have to know that
players are not allowed to agree on the
draw before move 30 and there is a
possibility today of an arm
get in playoff in group a we should take
a look at the playoff formats if that's
the case it would be a two-game rapid
match with both sides having 10 minutes
plus a two-second delay and if that
match is tied that goes down to an
Armageddon game where White has time
odds with five minutes plus few seconds
black would have four minutes plus two
second Crimmins with draw odds so it's a
very interesting scenario especially if
it comes down to Armageddon Calgary no
which side would you prefer in
Armageddon white with with extra time or
black with draw odds I have experience
with playing Armageddon games within
some tournaments and I always pick black
I usually catch up back with the time
and I really enjoy having to draw odds
because I don't like to you know to have
perpetual and not being able to to win
according to those rules so I pick
blacks to make sure that any time there
is a draw I am the one who is qualifying
I understand that but in Armageddon I
much prefer having the white side I like
the extra time especially in a blitz
game there aren't as many draws as in
classical chests and I like being able
to try and find the opponents and we do
want to know that Armageddon game if
there was one to happen it's gonna
happen today the player will start most
likely at 5:00 p.m. Central time so
let's take a look at the matchups
underway we'll start with the pairings
for Group A we have four games still
going between Jeffrey Zhang and Benjamin
Bach vernaccia mabye of against
Alexander in judge vara Cobian drawing
Daniel Friedman and a very quick game
I'm sure fr is hoping to gather playoff
spots and then we have the very crucial
game between Wasif Jerry Bailey tied for
first place against against Sam Sevilla
in third place if a thief wins that game
he'll be in he'll be the clear Group A
champion but if it's a draw or Sam wins
then it will force a playoff and then
last but not least we have Peter for
Houska against Yahoo Arabic and we have
two key matchups for this group the
first one is the borracho bein against
Daniel Friedman we have this very strong
American Grandmaster again German grill
master the game has already finished
players agreed on a draw and water is
virus the one who is waiting now to to
see where he is going to play a playoff
or whether
the winner and the other key matchup for
today is a fight between the sifter
Bailey and Sam said Ian there's a lot of
money riding on this game
let's take a glance and see what's going
on in the position we were taking a look
at earlier and I think we can tell just
based on the thief's expression he can't
be too happy kind of slumped over there
pondering his next move sounds away from
the board if we take a look at the
position we can see this monstrous
Knights on on the d4 square I think
black has everything to play for in this
position and we also see how black is
advancing on the Kings side I mean g5 h5
black definitely wants to break through
maybe with chief or creating a weakness
on e4 the point is gonna be for grabs
whether after we play d4 so i feel black
is the one who is very pleasant and very
happy with this position and white has
to do Waseem has to try to defend this
to make a draw in order to get to
playoffs yeah we'll certainly have to
keep an eye on this game I'm expecting a
very long fight given that okay black is
is clearly better but it's not
immediately winning and I'm sure players
are gonna fight very hard especially
because if it's the last round so let's
see the pairings for Group B we have
some exciting matches there we have
larger bells playing Daenerys adora
Kesava we have two quick draws already
were JT Ally Miranda drew Robert agus
Ariana and androids - copying drew Josh
freed air the last two games that are
being played Alejandra Ramirez against
today Fabri Hammond and Sergei Martin go
against Camille dragon and we had two
key matchups the matchup between andrey
zhuk open and josh fidel ended in a very
quick draw Andre had to win that game to
have any hopes for a playoff with
Camille dragon but I do want to show the
game and what happened it was a 12 move
draw they played into I think what is a
pretty well known line in the Queens
gambit accepted variation where after
Bishop c4 Andre actually went for a
fourth draw after Knight g5 sacrificing
his queen and then simply forcing the
perpetual check so perhaps Andre was
satisfied with just a quick game still
good standing in the tournament but but
not enough for first place I mean we
have to know that nine
it's a very long tournament players get
tired so sometimes you are just happy
with having draw in the last round to
finish it off and then move on to your
next next plans absolutely and the other
key matchup of today is the already
tournament winner a camille dragon
against Sergey Mott saenko they're still
fighting hard against each other and we
should note that they were roommates
during this event staying in the same
house so I think they probably have
gotten to know each other pretty well
but they're not agreeing to a quick draw
in the final round
perhaps Sergey is playing for more we
can see him very focused there Camille
is away from the board let's take a look
at the current position there have been
some updates since since when we looked
before the broadcast this pawn on d5 is
now a passed pawn probably a pretty
strong point for white in the position
not to mention the double fee and Cato
gives white props and chances in this
position yes we talked about it before
and we were very happy with Derek to see
all the white pieces being developed I
mean the rooks are amazing on files
bishops they developed an attacking also
I would like to know the pawns on the
Queen side I mean the a for b5 they are
creating more space for white and I
think even just a pleasant more pleasant
position for a white to play yeah and
I'm a bit suspicious of blacks last move
this pawn advance Pawnee for it just
seems weakening I'm wondering if whites
can maybe start looking for ways to
attack the pawn perhaps rook to c4 Queen
e3 just seems like white can build up a
lot of pressure not to mention that the
c5 pawn is also a target maybe potential
ideas of Bishop a3 so it seems like
White House a lot to play for in this
position so let's move on and review
prizes what are the players fighting for
yeah we have a very generous $22,000
prize went through group a with $6,000
for first place and right now it's only
Sam Savion version of Cobian and
received her Bailey who can fight for
the first place prize and the prize fund
for group B is also very nice it's a
total of fourteen thousand dollars the
winner takes $4,000 home it's clear it's
camel dragoon who's winning this price
very good tournament for him he must be
pleased absolutely and I mean with the
last round going there's uh there's a
lot of players fighting for various
prizes even if it's not for first place
there's still lots of money to fight for
so we should take a look at some of the
games and see what's transpiring a game
that catches my eye is a fight between
Peterborough Aska and Yarra jariabek
started as a relatively sharp King's
Indian and now they have a position with
kind of pieces scattered all over the
place but I do have to prefer white
given that white is currently up upon in
the position this d6 pawn is incredibly
weak and I mean it seems like Peter is
the one playing for a win I mean I
absolutely agree with you I like how
white species are more active I mean we
see the bishop on f8 that's that's a
very sad piece just staring at its own
pawn so probably why it's gonna retreat
with the bishop from b7 I mean we
probably such as something like Bishop
a3 just going back sure and aligned like
Bishop f3 black could win the pawn on b2
but then white ones upon in d6
I think it's just a clean pawn advantage
for white so yarrow might might not be
ending the tournament so well in this
game it is little surprising to see that
usually when one is winning on the board
he's also winning with the time or
having a better time advantage but we
see that Peter Prohaska has only 15
minutes whereas yarrow jariabek has 31
minutes oh I wonder what makes Peter
think too much here that's right I think
there are some complications earlier so
maybe he just took his took a lot of
time in the late opening early Melo game
to have navigate through through the
chaos in the position but let's move on
to another game there is many other
games that are catching my eye
maybe we can glance at the game between
Geoffrey Zhang and Benjamin Bach where
this has been a running theme throughout
the tournament Brooke end games where
one side is up upon I think every game
that we've seen white has had extra pawn
trying to grind out the position do you
think there's any hope for Geoffrey to
win this position and I just believe it
Benjamin was the one who had yesterday
pawn up so today yesterday was pawn up
he wasn't able to transfer that
advantage today he is pawn down and he
has to hold but they should be this
shouldn't be a difficult position to
haul to draw this is a pretty routine
draw especially with the time situation
I mean it's only a couple hours into the
round and both players are well past
move forty they're actually on with 55
so players playing very quickly and
after roof tee for the strategy for
black in this position is do not trade
rooks just keep your work on an active
square and if white wants to make any
progress you probably have to trade off
the a pair of pawns and then it's just
going to be a theoretically drawing game
yeah so black will just redraw and then
wait I mean black is very happy to have
King on g6 sometimes if the King is cut
off and it's somewhere far away from the
pond then these positions can be lost
but can get safe defending the opponent
f6 this should not be a difficult
situation to to hold to draw absolutely
so let's move onto to another game maybe
we can take a look at the fight between
Renacci mabye of and Alexander and judge
they have a what seems to be a very
imbalanced position I'm trying to count
material here it looks like white is
down the exchange but has two pawns for
it
any thoughts so every time we see amber
and suppose positions I like to see how
players are fighting and you see that
even who has the advantage is sometimes
not better in a way like here black has
exchanged up but most likely the bishops
are very strong I mean we saw a similar
theme in the game
JJ Ally Miranda against a teef abrahama
and where are these bishops they are
just such a huge force that is hard to
stop it reminds me of the Danish gambit
where you get these these two two
bishops on B 2 and C 4 early in the
opening staring down against the black
Kings side but White's last move does
not seem too impressive this for
treating with Bishop to e2 perhaps
unleashing the the battery on the C file
maybe considering the repositioning of
the bishop to FV perhaps to guard the
King sight but I do prefer Y in this
position and also another idea is Knight
c4 and Knight e5 just over free up that
square and bring the knight to a better
square
it's all about optimizing the pieces and
another idea I want to point out just
being inspired from the games yesterday
White has a pasty Pond and if white can
get the pawn to e5 it not only leads to
a very aesthetic looking pawn chain but
it would in to control the square on d6
so maybe white could someday get a
Knight to c4 and d6 and we see a very
powerful outpost in this position but
that takes a long time to do and we're
gonna have to see if Alexander can maybe
stir up some initiative before white
gets ideal so I do like the idea of a 45
but we do have to be careful about
making the knight on c6 too active
because any time we play before we free
up the d4 square for the knight and
that's something that we may not want to
do but let's move on somewhere else
because we do have a result between
Geoffrey Zhang and Benjamin Bach daruka
and game did and Apple has turned into a
king end game with nothing else on the
board let's see how that happens I'm
sure Jeffrey completely understands this
as the drought is really nothing to play
for so Brooks actually got traded I was
saying there shouldn't be a trade of
rooks
but I guess if black can simplify which
he did with the move f5 and it's just an
easy draw capture and Geoffrey did not
even play out the King pawn ending he
could play King III and play on it too
so mate he just played that for King
take off for solid way to finish the
tournament for both players nice draw so
let's move on and to see maybe 2k Marin
attuma by F against Alexandra in ditch
yeah we were just looking at game Bishop
e2 is played Alexander is thinking here
so maybe we can take a look at another
game let's go back to the the fight
between the CVR bailey and sam savvy and
because this is probably the most
critical game out of both groups just
for the the playoff possibility we were
saying earlier if a thief wins he he's
guaranteed first place but I think he's
on the worst side
Sam is playing for a win to force a
playoff against version dacovian Queen
h6 just played and it looks like black
is having some nice expansion on the
Kings side
maybe someday going for this chief for
push but it's a question of whether and
that White's forces are solid enough to
hold the position together I like the
move Queen eight series because it's a
it's a little wedding move like is
preparing maybe chief or maybe moving
just the pieces around but now it's
White's turn to make you move and why
this little tied up it white doesn't
have too many chances to to play form of
like let's say I play g3 or h3 every
move so weakened something and provides
a target for black so wide needs to
decide how to make the best move here
that does not worsen his position I
would be very uncomfortable as white
here I mean a big component in this
position is the fact that Knight is just
so powerful on d4 and this Bishop is
just staring in empty space on c4 it's
it's really having no no purpose in the
position that's usually not a good sign
when it's a battle between two minor
pieces so it is a question what is the
see if actually doing here it does you
have to play a waiting move the only
maybe somewhat active idea that I see is
some potential minority attack on the
Queen side something like a 4 and then
b5 but I don't know if this is really
achieving much for whites
I wonder what black is gonna do if I
make s why the waiting move let's say
Bishop d3 just to throw the ball on
black and say ok it's your turn are you
gonna play d4 or what is your plan yeah
that's an interesting point I mean as
plaque I would like to maybe improve
slightly more I feel a bit better with
this rook on f6 and maybe I can show a
line where I wanted to demonstrate a
line where this on some danger with
x-ray vision between the Queen's let's
give black I want to give black too many
moves in a row let's get black maybe
five moves ago just to demonstrate an
idea let's say rook f6 the bishop will
move back and forth
let's bring the King to e7 Bishop keeps
moving back and forth and then when the
time is right I would like to go for
this breakthrough g4 idea would be if if
pawn takes g4 rip take f2 now I'm
realizing this doesn't quite work
because a bishop
defending f1 so maybe this which is peer
trade and and black is it's not even
achieving so much with with so many
moves in a row but still white has to be
very careful about the x-ray about a
minority attack for black on the
kingside it's uncomfortable position I
see that massive just made the move a
four to try the attack on the queenside
yeah let's cut to the current position
plenty for it played yeah putting the
ball in in box courts and now it's a
question how to make progress I'm sure
Sam will be maybe a bit more accurate in
the way he proceeds in the position
compared to me but it's just a question
how to break through do you go for g4 at
some point you go for the H pawn push
and we'll have to wait and see
so before we wait how they gonna proceed
let's look at the game bloody battles
against Daenerys at huaca Silva
I thought it was a very interesting idea
that what you mean I decided to to make
in the opening and suddenly again we
have an unbalanced position promising
game yeah let's go back to the opening
because we have like a very standard
Hedgehog setup after Knight takes d4 I
mean you see this these types of
positions among high-level players so
often but flatty mayor chose the very
unexpected and very ambitious Knight d2
b5 hitting the Queen on c7 also hitting
the pawn on d6 and it led to some one
interesting material balance after a
pawn take Knights and I take b5 Queen b8
and I take T six white one a few pawns
and is also winning the exchange we
should point out that black can't really
save the rook from from c8 if the rook
moves to c7 why it would have the
straight forward tactic and I take b7
and then whatever takes back light would
then have a five winning a significant
amount of material the bishop on b6 b7
is really important and whenever white
gets it then white bishop on g2 just
become such a strong force with 35 I
really like this idea of 95 and
sacrificing a knight
yeah so what happened in the game dinara
chose just to give up the rook on c8
played the movie 5 perhaps trying to
to get the bishop on g2 maybe a bit a
bit more passive given that the pawn is
now fixed on e4
but after Knight takes see a truck takes
c8 we see an interesting material
imbalance black having two knights and
white having a rook into pawns what side
would you prefer in this position I
realize the white pawns I mean the
center is great the e4 c4 I will a
really strong pawns we have a future it
may be before c5 having a passport
I always favor I mean not always but you
should I figure out the pieces that have
the pair of Bishop with the pawns going
forward because the bishops are great
supporters I would choose white here
yeah it's it's unbalanced I don't know
if I'm not heavy favorite for whites
because I do like having more minor
pieces especially if you have like two
minor pieces for a rook and my one of my
very first chess coaches taught me that
two minor pieces is about equivalent to
rook into pawns
just because two minor pieces can
coordinate better together so I think
it's going to be a close fight I think
there probably should be chances for
both sides let's zoom forward and see
what the current position is the bishop
traded off on be six and after rook to
e3 Bishop f8 rook IDI one brings us to
the current position where it seems like
white is very comfortable dominating the
only open file on the board it just
seems like better harmony for White's
position yeah I'm sad to see that the
light square bishop disappeared but on
the good side is that we to control the
D file and black pieces cannot just
regroup very easily so we seen I don't
f6 which is just not very strong I mean
the knight is not it's a technique
before but that's defended by pawn on
every it can't go anywhere else
so maybe white is the one who is just
waiting how to proceed on the Queen side
yeah I just seems uncomfortable for
black and white will start having
looming threats of something like rook
e8 maybe reposition the bishop and go
for ideas like Bishop h6 so it doesn't
seem that Pleasant for dinara we can see
she's very focused on the board with
with Vladimir leaning back and getting
I'm taking a walk away from the board
and the nura's time is taking down less
than 15 minutes to make make about 14
moves so not much time to to play the
next several moves so what if you move
on to the game Alejandra Ramirez and
Tata Fabri Hawaiian we did not look
there yet and I thought it's an also
interesting position we have a pair of
bishop for white and what is the
material otherwise the material is equal
nobody has any advantage yeah I mean
both sides have somewhat damaged pawn
structure we can see these double pawns
for Alejandra on the King side but an
isolated pawn for Tata of on d5 seems
somewhat in balance but I would have to
prefer white in this position having two
bishops in a very open position and I
think in this game we'll see how to
bishops can overpower two knights and I
really like they move that happen we
should be one I remember watching strong
grandmasters playing games with these
two bishops and crimeny was saying that
bishops are really strong even if they
are on the first rank because they have
the potential of attacking any squares
and really be very powerful so I like
how the bishops are on b1 and b2 maybe
are not developed perfectly but they
control so many squares and they can
move to more active spaces at any time
absolutely and I think Alejandra just
wants to play the simple a3 next kick
the neither way force it back to c6
where it's it's far less productive and
then maybe reactivate the LightSquared
Bishop may be a move like like soon a
bit Bishop d3 and go after blocked
structure on the Queen side not to
mention that black is always going to
have to worry about the vise 85 fun so I
think White has a lot to play for that's
true because black cannot just move away
with the Knights to try to regroup them
because the pond would always be a
weakness I mean how do you think black
can proceed here when we know the easy
plan for white is just to a3 push the
night away and then just to improve the
bishops that's a great question I it's
hard to find a plan here for a black
like both nights just seem very
restricted this mile-an-hour six we saw
this idea and
another game where it's just restricted
by the f3 pawn it can't really find the
better square so I think it's a question
if if Tata if can somehow optimize
optimize the Knights but it's it's not
easy given given that the d5 pawn always
needs to be defended and there's always
a potential like whenever Alejandra
wants to he can probably play a move
like Bishop take Knights for example
this should take f6 and and destroy Tata
as pawn structure even further so I
think we're gonna see a nice positional
grind down by Alejandro in this game
yeah it's certainly a more pleasure of
better position for white we do have one
more move played pawn to e5 I don't
think that changes too much in the
position I'm expecting something like a3
and Alejandro will be patient maybe try
and have a long game given that Tata is
already pretty low on time let's move 27
and talk to there's already under six
minutes so she's gonna have to play a
bit quicker the next several moves so
let's see an under a game do you want to
go over to draw JJ Ellie Miranda Robert
I guess Ariana we could that might put
me to sleep but we could we could take a
quick look we had an opening which comes
from pretty common common line that you
see a lot in scholastic just the Scotch
variation four nights after d4 take take
I used to play this opening myself for
both sides when I was younger but as I I
became a more experienced player I
realized these positions are relatively
dry not too much to play for and usually
players who go into these lines are just
looking to play safe for either side and
it seemed like neither player in this
game was really going for too much
especially after Knight f5 and the trade
bishop for nights leading to a position
with office of color bishops and this
already makes me a bit sleepy so going
for it even further Brooks got traded
and then there was just nothing to play
for I think they they got to know 31 and
they may they just agreed to draw
so we had a nice I thought it Robert
yeah Robert is the player who did not
lose any single game in this tournament
very solid won eight draws and one win
its do you remember having a tournament
like this I mean that's incredibly solid
that's a nice carry like in the sense
that there's just so many draws but
having one win as to make it a bit a bit
nice for him given that he finished on a
plus one score and that's a really
authentic plus one score only having one
win and then the rest draws so it can't
be too disappointed with that result and
I'm sure he's going to take away a lot
of prize money yes so I see some changes
in the game like you know Bella's
against Daenerys Erica so ah what
happened too many moves were played yeah
well when we last look there was a
pretty hefty material imbalance and now
material is equal if I can count
correctly let's go back and see what
happened because we saw white dominating
the d-file Donora play the very sensible
move Bishop e7 preventing any
possibilities with rook e8 and sometimes
this is a this is a common strategy if
your opponent is dominating an open file
on the board then you just want to
control any entry point along that open
file we can actually see in this
position black is controlling all of
these squares so even though White's
rooks are doubled there's no way to make
them more useful going for in the
position we see Bishop c1 and then
dinara went for blank for some tactics
might take E for I'm wondering if
Vladimir just missed this move but it
seems like a simple tactical shot
leading to material equality after
Bishop takes e4 rook da check some
trades occurred and now it's its Queen
rook and bishops and some pawns for you
sided I'm a little puzzled by the move
Bishop c1 I mean what is the idea I
thought it'd be sure won't be too is
kind of good at I can do pawn on e5 and
maybe we could maybe we could do
something like Queen e2 Queen e3 improve
the Queen will win but Bishop c1 do you
think he wanted to go Bishop e3 year or
it seemed yeah it seems logical that the
bishop is much better placed on e3 but I
think he probably should have started
with Queen e2 for that reason of
any night taking four possibilities but
we've seen Vladimir this tournament may
be missing some some tactics that he
should see on a better day reminds me of
the first round where he just missed
like a to move combination that lost
material so maybe he's not in the best
form but the the current position still
seems very playable if we see what
happened we have a position it's equal
material but very imbalanced given the
pawn majorities on the on the Queen side
White has three on one but on the King
side Black has four on two so there's
still some fight for both sides I'm not
sure not actually sure which players
matter here I think it's very important
for a white to control the D file so I
wonder if black and display rook d6 and
try to trade rook t6 is an interesting
attempt to simplify the position we
should note that Queen take if I would
not be possible due to rotate to you on
winning everything
so after rook d6 then it's a question
what does white do do you trade rooks or
do you keep rooks on the board maybe I
could go for something like rook d5 just
going after this you point given that it
is fixed on the dark square and perhaps
follow up with something like there
should be two and it does seem a bit
more pleasant for whites
I think d5 is a strong move Nora is
thinking in this position and I think it
is a bit more pleasant for for a white
just overall given that black has two
pawns pretty much fixed in dark squares
and with the presence of the oxford
bishops it's hard to it's hard to be
happy as black in this position given
that white has targets to attack and
black doesn't necessarily have a clear
target to attack in this position
probably has to resort to do and white
really controls the d5 and the Queen
efore is amazing because it also lets
say black wants to play a 5 to just gain
some space then I can always move my
Queen to d5 and make another pain
controller d5 even more it's it looks it
looks like black may be okay after f5 or
some interesting
but actually Black is just weakening his
bone structure and his king that's right
I can't be too happy and in the Norris
situation she said that a very good
result so far being I believe the night
scene in the event and scoring scoring
at least fifty percent but a loss today
can't can't be the best way for her to
finish the Germans so let's see what
else can black and do I think I want to
stay a little bit more with this
position because I think it's an
interesting one compared compared to the
others well Queen see it was played so
now it's White's move and that's a
question what does white do what's the
best way to maybe push for some more
advantage here oh we do have a move that
was played Bishop to e3 played
relatively quickly just optimizing the
bishop why not the bishop has potential
to play on both sides of the board and
now black has to constantly be worried
about this b6 pawn it is currently
defended by the rook and the bishop
but it seems like White's just looking
to improve maybe go for some eventual
move like c5 but seems like white isn't
in any rush here it's just a matter of
improving even further exactly I think
white can play even like Queen da2 then
h4 and it's very hard for black to find
some some good moves because you have to
be careful let's say if okay now it's
blacks turn yeah so what to do if you're
dinara so let's say blacks play
something like King g7 just a random
movement and I play Queen d5 suddenly
black ice to decide where you want to
put the bishop and it's an important
decision because either b6 is gonna be
weak or the bishop is gonna be blocking
the Queen allowing Y to advance on the
Queen side
that's very true a move like Bishop c7
comes to mind with the threat of rook d6
actually that's probably not a threat
cuz he five would be hanging so it just
seems like just lack of space for black
I feel a bit claustrophobic looking at
this position given that black doesn't
have much room to work with and white is
controlling so many key squares all over
the board there was a move played not
King g7 but Bishop to e7
brings us to the current position and
I'm glad I'm here playing with this hair
they're pondering what to do next
I feel like Krug d5 is a very natural
move we are improving Derek we don't
want to have the Queen in front of the
rug because of the tactics that you
mentioned maybe Ruby 6 can be actually
at acting here
the King is no longer on g7 so there's
no check with taking the pawn so roughly
5 seems like a very natural and nice
move
we are attacking the pawn on e5 we can
then bring the Queen to d3 to even
double on the D file any other
suggestions sure
not at the moment I mean I think
Vladimir is gonna take his time trying
and milk the position trying as much out
of it as he can we do have a question
from the YouTube chat from chief Dane
does so do a cassava get a GM norm I
think it depends on the result of this
game I actually don't know maybe the
people in back and do some research for
us but so the audience is 2580 and to
claimant Jim norm you have to have about
2600 so I believe if she wins this game
she should be able to claim a GM no but
that's not confirmed that's only
speculation speculation yeah sometimes
when you're close to getting a norm
there's there's a lot of technicalities
that can come into play I've been there
many times myself I've been getting
trying to get the ions highlight it's
close so many times but missed it in the
last round and it takes a lot of
patience and perseverance until you can
until you can get a normal speaking
about I'm title I already have about 11
norms all I am missing is just rating
for the past eight years I believe so
it's it's difficult it takes a lot of
time and you have to you have to be
persistent I think Tata vis in the same
scenario right she has at least eight I
am norms and her peak rating fee day was
like twenty three ninety four and
sometimes they crushed the 2400
threshold it it just takes it takes a
lot of work and you have to be
consistent so let's look at the game of
the leader camel dragon or actually we
can say the winner of the group B there
there are some changes the pond on b5 is
no longer there
what let's go back and see how the
position reached its current states 'if
i was played i think we left off around
here after efore and I was criticizing
this this epon that it might be a bit
weak in the future but we see within
just a few moves black was able to
support the e pawn and then play at the
very solidifying pawn f5 which really
reinforces the pawn structure but maybe
makes the bishop a bit sad on h7 I am
envisioning some ideas for black in the
future like King h8 and Bishop to g8 so
maybe target the d5 pawn a few more
moves have been played b6 from White's
somewhat unexpected looks like just upon
sacrifice I just look at a time and I'm
trying to see what tactic is there but I
think it's just a positional sacrifice
where you want to get a B file you want
to bring the rook there you want to put
pressure on c5 but still it's it's a
pawn is it a pawn but a half-open file
is a half-open file you don't see these
positional sacrifices too often in such
positions but maybe here it makes sense
given that the B the half-open VfB file
is going to be very nice for White's a
few more moves have been played Bishop
to a3 pressuring the pawn on c5 white
now has three attackers between the
bishop the rook and the Queen
so this prompted black to play rook to
c8 and going forward here white played
rook to c1 now having four attackers
doesn't look like there's any way for a
white to are for black to defend the
b-pawn maybe this is a whole idea of
playing this v-6 move it prevented
platform playing pong in e6 it seems
like so black cause it was just a
temporary sacrifice where white push the
bond to be six forcing the Queen to go
there and then putting pressure on C
file C file and c5 pawn and just getting
the pawn back that's right bishop g6 was
played and now it's it's White's move
Sergei is thinking should he take the
pawn next or is there maybe something
else to do in the position it seems like
the logical move is Bishop takes e5 I
don't see
I don't really see how to option mm-hmm
yep so maybe we can speculate some line
here at Bishop takes e5 this ship takes
c5 rook takes e5 there could be a lot of
trades resulting in some kind of rook
Bishop ending where you would probably
have to favor White's given that blacks
pawns especially these this pawn on f5
is an implant on e4 are fixed on light
squares and we've seen this theme so
many times bishops of the same color and
again you want your pawns on a different
color than the bishop and one thing is
the bishops but also look at the pieces
I mean the rook on a it is just so
passive the bishop on g6 is not great
and compared to that the white
reconceive is very active and the bishop
on g2 has quick future on let's say
bishop if guan Bishop e5 to be active
and control some nice squares yeah I
think little seems like Sergei is
playing for a win
maybe fighting if not for first place
he's fighting for a share of of maybe
second or third place might be a tough
finish if Camille loses his last round
but still wins a tournament but
sometimes that's that's a case in these
long tournaments so let's switch gears
and go back to trauma and a we did not
spend spend much time there maybe Peter
Prohaska in a garage or a book on this
game certainly heating up the last move
Bishop d5 played seems like Peter is
still the one pushing for a win despite
the time deficit I really admire lights
activity in this position by and
counting material last time we were
looking white was seems to be up upon
but now White's down upon but perhaps
just is going for a an attack against
the Kings side yes because the King is a
weak and let's say we let's pack your
life in black takes Bishop takes d5
Knight takes d5 now we are putting
pressure on the pinned piece on f6 the
knight is hanging and if black plays a
move let's say Bishop g7 I thought there
is rugby eight problem but actually
there's maybe 98 and black this far
98
but can we continue in a happy way maybe
97 and losing the Queen uh oh yeah I
forgot about take t4 that's rough
so Brooke take g8 maybe but that doesn't
seem to work either oh that's
interesting
I should cook take geh King take GA 97
King f7 only move and both queens are
attacked but the knight is also attacked
97 we can go for something like Queen c4
tried to take the rook but there is aa
here okay maybe this idea is it's not
great but we see some chances on the on
the diagonal opening the opening tonight
and using the very active rook on b8 but
we have a more fruit c2 happened
rook see - feels like a better choice
now allowing light to exert too much
pressure against this knight on f6
and now it's White's move what to do
you're down the pawn looks like a fun
position though it's just a question how
to make progress
I feel like 96 maybe it's a good move if
whites or blacks gonna tell you tonight
I'm gonna have a pair of bishop I'll be
very happy the light-square bishop will
be attacking pawn on f5 there is
certainly compensation I like that idea
yeah just 96 going for positional play
we should note that every single black
pawn is isolated in position white has
beautiful pawn structure on the Kings
side given that King has a very nice
shelter on from g1 so maybe instead of
going for just the crashing breakthrough
White's just maybe going for some
positional endgame where he can he can
grind down the black side so our
prediction is here 96 is there any other
move we have to know that Peter has only
less than five minutes and too many
moves happened so Roxy - Ruby 8 happened
again somebody coming for the attack I
mean Bishop g7 played breaking the tin
but check my drug takes g8 almost
technique yeah
almost yeah if if tonight is not enough
six it would be checkmate but okay black
is is employing this this cocoon
mechanism he's just trying to hollow in
a ball and survive until the weather
gets better but what to do in this
position as white how do you break
through it just seems like it seems like
Black Sabbath is is really solid on the
Kings side and we can note interesting
variation for less experienced players
they can think about Queen takes f6 to
really go for the checkmate but we do
have to be careful so let's say Queen
takes the Queen Queen takes f6 Queen
takes f6 there is this checkmate rook
takes g8 but we have to be careful about
the choices that Black has after Queen
takes f6 because after Bishop takes f6
the Queen is actually defending the
bishop on g8 so there is no checkmate
and the sacrifice is more like lost well
there have been more moves played let's
get to the current position because okay
of course Queen take f6 not played
bishop take g8 was played pretty forcing
move and after Knight take g8 very
simple Queen d5 threatening made in one
how to defend her black so I have to
move the bishop away probably something
like Bishop a1 such an awkward running
across the board allowing the Queen to
defend the knight but this can not be
pleasant for black it just seems like
White has so much potential with all the
pieces on the board the Queen on g5 work
on BA maybe the bishop can enough work
and get him to play you may be sure can
just take Bishop takes d6
threatening going back to Bishop e5 and
attacking the king that's incredibly
logical yeah Bishop take d6 just seems
so crushing it doesn't seem like black
has any counter play just given the the
safety of a like King on g1 so you can
see yarrow is thinking in this position
but there's not too many moves to
consider
Turkey is just considering where to move
the bishop from g7
here interesting interesting variation
here I'm looking at some chances with
maybe Bishop a1 let's try that Bishop
takes these six now rook c1 check cage -
king h2 and no I thought maybe just
eight six just to make space for it I
know it it's a little unhappy wait give
them that
okay now White has pretty much a free
move looking here maybe 96 just bring
the knight towards the Kings side still
going for a Bishop to e5 and just seems
very unpleasant for black so let's so
let's move back maybe not maybe no check
on c1 maybe I can go something like
Queen g7 Queens u7 but again I just want
to play 96 I want to prepare this Bishop
e5 move but now I have I'm also
considering ideas like 98 f7 it just
seems like White's pieces are curling
all over black and maybe we can see how
these pieces are just having perfect
cooperation all are very active - rock
on b8 pinning the knight the bishop is
very strong to weak like weak dark
squares around the black ink this is one
of the positions that is very hard to
play for for black I think we can put
our money heavily on Peter this game
peter hasn't had the best performances
tournament but a win in the last round
is always nice I usually like to think
that even if you have a bad tournament
or not the best tournament if you win
the last round at least it leaves a good
taste in your life and that will be the
first winner actually for Peter he has
seven six drawers and two losses so this
is we first first win in the last round
definitely leaving a nice day
about a tournament so let's move on
let's see how the other games are
unfolding looking for the thief Tara
Bailey game we should keep an eye on
this game as it is the most crucial game
for the tournament some moves have been
played since we last left I think we
last left after the seif played a fork
on move 28 and let's see what Sam was up
to he went for Queen d6 perhaps just
centralizing the Queen beef I played the
sieve going for the minority attack
Queen c5 so Sam appears to have found a
better square for the Queen
maybe going for x-ray vision along this
diagonal also hitting the bishop on c4
the c4 treated with the bishop very
quiet move King h7 maybe the king is
better than a seven and any other swear
and again black has time black and just
move around
it is white who has difficulties finding
boots good spots good squares that's
it's very true and after king h1 I mean
the ball is still in Sam's court
sometimes this is the case when you're
attacking you're the one who has to make
progress in the position and I would
think that's why Salmons Loren time he's
the one switching for ideas while the
see if is just the one kind of waiting
around playing a move like king h1
really putting the question how is back
breaking through and I want to just show
of a nice idea so let's say White was
not going to play king h1 I just take
back this move and why would play a bad
move but let's see it be sure b1 now
black has a great tactical choice Knight
takes a free here I was going to tell
the viewers to pause the stream so they
could find the move but yeah and I take
f3 so let's boss what happens after rook
takes a free yeah I Brooke take our
three black to move and destroy white
it's very simple Queen take III rook
take III and checkmate
one so we see White has some issues that
he has to deal with so that's why he
played King H want to make sure the king
is out of that Diagon there are no
problems on f3 because anytime you take
on f3 right now I can take back the
Queen on c5 so this way we are keeping
the king king a little safe and hoping
for the best for sure
I'm curious here is Sam maybe fathoming
the the break g4 in this position has he
optimized everything where now it's time
to go for the breakthrough given the
King on h1 maybe not defending that
we're kind of - enough would this lead
to anything so let's see so if I take
the pawn I mean I have to consider that
because if I don't take such a ideal
would be to take on f2 to rook take F to
Queen takes and then Queen c1 check but
I'm not sure if this is leading to
anything so bishops F 1 F 1 the argument
here would be the the Queen and Knight
combination is better than the Queen
Bishop combination but perhaps we can
see the black king is left pretty unsafe
on h7 white has ideas of simply Queen f7
so maybe this wouldn't be the best
continuation of her black but like at
some choices like this now I do want to
stay with this game because it's very
interesting but I'm looking at what's
happening in the Ronettes Alexandra
ended games so can we just go there
White's King very precariously placed on
d2 and rook da check played we were
looking earlier we saw white was down
the exchange for for two pawns now we
see white is just up two pawns but
getting getting massively attacked so
can we go maybe back to morph like I'm
afraid to see what folded so white did
go for this 95 move I think we lost left
after Bishop e2 lots of moves have been
played
we should zoom to the current position
because we're not is severely low on
time and oh no our score sheets being
signed too
or not I don't have the results yet my
comer they're about to put Kings in the
center of the board looks like for now
it does not look very happy it's not too
happy about the results and just did win
the game though the Kings on dark
squares in the center not the best term
infer or not so let's just see what
happened because there was a very nice
sacrifice I think for black to give an
exchange yeah it seems like Bach was was
just invading on the Kings side going
for killer move between g2 forcing light
to play this awkward offensive of rook T
- it just seems like black is having all
the fun Bishop c1 and then beautiful
sacrifice here rook take E - can you
take E - and then it's just a forcing
line after Queen G for this is such a
nice position sacrifice where black is
taking control of all the likes light
squares around the King and suddenly the
king is in trouble
yeah there's nowhere to hide then
there's nowhere to run so I mean we're
not tried running with the King but it
did not last too long after Kings III
and Queen e2 looks like Nathan's
unstoppable Queen c2 mates is a threat
and just look at White's pieces doing
nothing to help defend against the
meaning attacks
so let's look what would happen where
why to play not king d - but King Jiwon
Akemi one perhaps another try but I'm
assuming that perhaps Bishop c2 is there
anything more direct maybe just a simple
work - das oh then you force me to play
Bishop d2 and then you have Bishop c2
right so let's see Bishop d2 -
preventing that checkmate
and then Bishop Bishop C - I'm not going
for this Queen d1 move just seems like
especially in these situations with
asakari bishops it's so hard for a white
to defend against all these like squares
very nice tactics very nice positional
sacrifice who takes it to Alexandra
indeed she's finishing the tournament
with a
with a nice win and we have another
result where Peter Prohaska born again
yarrow Cheryl boo-boos Rojas did score
the last win was just a glance at how
the game ended going back it just seems
so fun for a white after Queen to defy
Bishop f6 was played and then 98
beautiful moves going on the last rink
and after Ruby to Erick a eight seems
like yarrow had enough in this position
just giving the given that White has all
the pieces going for the attack night
take f6 being the clear threats d6 pawn
hanging I'm assuming that night 86 and
907 is also with threats nothing to tell
for it's black in this position so let's
say if black played Bishop c3 just to
move away so business III yes Oh
probably just 96 is good enough to win a
night they accept 7 here that's a 7 or
Bishop e5 coming there's a funny line
just to demonstrate some smothered mate
let's say black plays a waiting move
Bishop e5 trade on e5 27 this could be
one potential final me in the position I
mean this is sometimes what happens if
you have active pieces you are moving
away moving toward the King just there
are tactics happening that you can you
don't have to see at the beginning they
just happen there because of having such
great pieces exactly and we have another
result in Group B Alejandra defeating
talked about raha me and we can see
neither player at the board there I
think like two or three results came in
there within just within the span of
just a minute maybe just two of them but
let's see the final position going
forward here I mean that the two bishops
just seems to be so dominant and we can
see that Alejandra was already up upon
it looks like talkative went for the
sacrifice of the D pawn charms to free
up some squares but maybe she just
blundered after tea for did she miss
Bishop take to you for simple back rank
made tactics I mean it is possible again
is the last round players are playing
nine days in nine
in a row long games you can blunder it
can happen and it seemed like
Alejandro's endgame technique very
stable here just two bishops against two
knights we can see how overpowering
White's position is given the activity
and given just that the National
Coordination that the two bishops have
in such positions I mean very nice
position to illustrate the power of
Bishops how they are really strong by
controlling so many diagonals and
restricting Knights from from any
movements exactly and just seem like
black has no hope in this position
Tata of resigns given the pressure that
White has in the position is everything
seems to be to be targeted not to
mention the King on g8 still some
looming ideas that back drink mates so
tough tough finish frittatas so we have
last three round last three games
playing let's take a look at Sergey
Matenga against camel dragon we may have
a rogue and game there yeah and as we
look at the the group be winner Kamil
dragon both players are actually getting
relatively long time
Camille is under five minutes now with
seven moves to go until time until time
is added on the clock Queen takes e5
just played and if I'm counting
correctly white is up upon and after
Queen takes e5 we should note that rook
is hanging on e4 but if Queen takes e5
White has an intermediate rook take
Yates
worth taking it and takes e5 it seems
like White's playing for a win but you
never know these work endings it could
liquidating I mean White has a pawn app
so black we will first need to recapture
the pawn and then the a5 is weak I think
this would be a difficult rook endgame
actually to play for black and I see
that black did not go for this endgame
and Camille chose to play queen g6 at
queen g6 certainly an idea in the
position kicking look at White's King
not the most sheltered piece on g1 given
the pawn in g4 and now black is both
targeting the pawn on g4 and the rook on
e4
I do like this move I mean if your
opponent's king is less safe keep
on the board absolutely and you know put
some pressure on the pond on g4 on the
rook now it's Sergei to decide what to
do I mean it's not that easy to probably
look a for Roxy for the rookies attack I
do have to move it I cannot even defend
it because that would not save the rook
we have moves coming through the forest
played 23 d3 seems like White has a lot
of weaknesses to worry about I'm
wondering if Camille wants to finish
with icing on the cake and finish strong
with a win seems like he's I mean he's
pretty much forced to go for for active
play in this position
Sergei currently thinking this pawn on
e3 is undefended the pawn on d5
potential weakness seems like whites
under some pressure here
I wonder if white can go rook F Luke cf1
for the seventh rank so what's a look
cf1 you take with Queen on e3 take take
seven you always like to to have we saw
a couple games yesterday yesterday there
was a big theme so today we can try to
repeat it because my goal is to hit the
pawn on b7 you have to defend it and
then I want to move the rook and bring
another rook to the seventh rank I'm
wondering if some of these lines could
just like turn into a draw at 48 let's
say you take on a seven row take here
some of these lines feel that Josh after
it moved like like rook D - I feel like
white probably would have to bail out
with some kind of perpetual check so
let's take a look at the current
standings we had many games that had
finished what is the current standing in
Group B group a group a we only have the
one game still pending receive Sarah
Bailey against Sam 7 all the other games
appear to have finished and if a thief
wins the game of curse he you leapfrogs
Varco bian to finish in first place but
he is the one defending so if you can
hold on for a draw he'll force a playoff
against bar but if Sam can win then
he'll have the playoff against bar yes
it's the last game but a very crucial
game it decides who is the winner if
there is a playoff well
it's nice to have such an ending where
it's not clear who is actually the
winner until the very very last round no
game it's true and what do you do in
your invar situation I mean he's just
maybe sitting back sipping some iced tea
watching the the battle being played out
and whoever if our plays will maybe be a
bit tired given that it's such a long
and intense battle yeah before the
broadcast I just saw him upstairs and he
was just talking to players playing some
chess
maybe he just wants to be relaxed and
ready to to focus again if there is a
playoff sure we should take a look at
the game between the CH and sound
because things have changed looks like
Sam my first some kind of breakthrough
or did you see code for the breakthrough
see what's going on here
we left after king h1 and players are in
time trouble there
they have about four moves to make until
till move 40 after Queen to e7 g3 and
only we were expecting this received our
Bailey going for the breakthrough with
f4 perhaps trying to destabilize a
knight on d4 and also creates some some
more open lines to get to the black King
yeah we were saying that maybe white
wants to not make such moves like h3 g3
to weaken the position around the King
on the other hand like going for h3 f4
it allows us to put pressure on the
knight on d4 all to advance the pawn to
f5 which bring us more space so it's a
very nice aggressive takeover of the
position I really like how chief has
handled this and it seems like maybe
he's not worth any more given that the
position is opening up it doesn't seem
like black's pawn and e5 is going to
stay there much longer and if the
position opens up even more than the
bishop could be superior to the knight
in some some future cases so what are
our predictions - for black here I do
want to note it's very strange that
massif is away from the board
with less than five minutes in the talk
we see Sam just played his his last move
it looks like he captured the Queen on
g3 having trouble making that out that
Queen take g3 was played by Citibank
near the ward recapturing the Queen
immediately
and now White has has kind of fixed upon
structure has some nice nice King site
pawn island meanwhile look at Sam's pawn
structure Khan's got it all over the
place and mmm there's some possibility
that massif could be playing for win in
this game we do have to keep in mind and
I don't mind that the knight on d4 is
still very strong and the bishop on d3
is staring at its own Bishop so it's so
the question is how to play for black
here if I'm not gonna for sure take on
the point on afford to make two
connected passed pawns I see that route
g7 just happened attacking the pawn on
g3 g7 plates
standing hovering over the port as Wasif
is pondering his next move taking a sip
of water
now Sam has initiative here that's a
good point
and there there might be a new target in
position the rooks appear to be shifting
over files and this g3 pawn is a bit
backwards given it can't move forward
due to the pawn in h5 and now it's a
question what to do as Wasif maybe the
simple King h2 or what if I take the
pawn on e5 I'm just going for trades
planting key files because at least this
time I do not is not defended on d4
anymore Essex can be a future I can go
for promotion at some point and I do
want to trade rogues because I feel my
rooks were stuck on the a file for a
very long time yeah so we can speculate
some line here if if pawn to g5 rook
take F 2 or take F to rotate III Sam
wins the pawn back attacks the bishop
bishop would probably have to move let's
say Bishop c4 it seems like ugly pawn
structure for both sides but maybe I
would have to choose white here just
given that the bishop is usually more
effective in these situations with pawns
on both sides of the board and if I fall
looks caring a little bit won't you
think if I fight yeah I mean with the
threat upon e6 ideas of rook f7 I'm sure
the chief is considering this but Sam
appears to be pretty comfortable just
kind of walking around
maybe he's nervous maybe he's just
pacing not sure what's going on but the
Seif to move both sides just over three
minutes left any other moves received
can be considering other than pawn to e5
so you said King h2 so let's see if
white plays king h2 maybe black can
respond with rook fg8 probably the idea
to put more pressure on g3 hit the pond
try to take it yeah it just seems uh
maybe simple for luck to play in this
position would then have to choose a
move like rook g2 or rip to g1 let's say
Saybrook to g2 that maybe who Sam could
could hit yeah white with this move pawn
h4 and there's just so much pressure
against this pawn and g3
bassy has less than three minutes so
he's still thinking he he may not want
to go for pawn takes e5 so what else is
there if not one takes e5 and not King H
- Sam Sam just pacing back and forth I
don't see this too often where like
you're in time trouble but you you're
just walking back and forth from the
board I'm sure Sam is continuing to
calculate strong grandmasters can do
that where they don't have to be looking
at the position to to calculate a heavy
I'm sure he has a position cemented in
his mind maybe it's somewhat annoying
for received for his opponent - just
people walking back and forth like that
yeah he has to make a tough decision
here and he sees the player walking
around and we see that he's only 90
sorry just Wendling yeah it looks like
the this clock might be slightly
inaccurate I saw was having less than a
minute and 30 seconds on that shot so
not much time to think and these
situations are difficult when when
you're in a critical moment and you just
have to rely on instinct and you don't
have that much time to calculate so I'm
curious what bassy is gonna choose so
let's stay with this game I hope Davis
is gonna play fast I mean he has to
I see minute and 13 seconds I mean
there's only three more moves to make
until the 40 I mean if I had to put
money
the next move I think this line with F
take e5 is most likely just given the
resulting position given the opening of
that file and really all of the CF needs
is a draw in this game it's a fourth
supply off so I mean he doesn't want to
take too much risk and risk potentially
losing this game and he already spent
four minutes on this move and finally he
made a move what did he play that's hard
located upon he played rubgy - IG -
maybe just going for defense I think we
can expect rook g8 from Sam we forgot to
mention though that if black plays rook
e8 in this position white could then
consider taking on e5 and might lead to
some slightly different scenario so
what's the difference so let's see roof
g8 take on e5 I'm probably expected
Brooke take g3 here I do want to trade
it takes you three then the bishop is
hit on d3 so I go bishops more similar
to the other line it's a very
interesting line let's say black by zero
rooks e3 to hit the bishop I can play a
6mm that's a nice idea when your pawn is
far enough advanced sometimes you don't
care about any other of your other
pieces you just care about cleaning your
pawn exactly because if the rook takes
the bishop now I play a seven and that
pawn is unstoppable that's a very nice
line the knight in the rut being
completely out of play
so yeah maybe if a thief is going for a
line like this where pawn on e5 even
though there's double pawns on the
e-file the the advance upon could spell
some trouble for black so now it's Sam
who is to move and he has two minutes to
to decide what to do he's not walking
around the board anymore he's thinking
harder - what to play now yeah and it
seems like a critical moment for Sam I
mean we were expecting or calf g8 but
I'm wondering is he considering any
other options here
it's difficult position I mean this
seems like there there's some options
maybe there is no immediate threat from
white it's just a question how to
continue as black could you do try and
force matters do you play some improving
the
maybe a move like c5 or a5 just to put
the ball in lights chords I just want to
make sure that we stress the pawns I
mean look at the pawns how isolated they
are they're just so weak
yeah I mean flax pawn structure not
ideal but I mean it's it's all about
kind of the the long-term positions
which could be reached and I feel like a
lot of these positions the the bishop in
the long term could could outperform the
Knights but as we saw in the milling in
the night with superior and we do have a
move sand plate h4 h4 unexpected this
seems like at first it seems like a pawn
sacrifice but it is attempting to
perhaps when the pawn on f4 and looks
like this he's quickly captured on h4
which leads to some kind of trade was f4
currently being hanging I must say that
I'm surprised by this variation because
if same night now takes the rook King
takes the rook I mean we won't have the
connecting bones as white as we wanted
to so probably it's true Quan takes on a
four loop takes to take out four but I
mean I feel like white is still the one
to choose in this position given the
Bishop versus Knight scenario we're
seeing this line being played out rook
takes you to played we can expect king
king take g2 and then that's a question
for Sam do you take on a fourth upon or
the rook I mean usually the rule is not
to trade pieces when you are material
down the material is equal here but the
bishop has better potential I feel like
the cooperation between the rook and
Bishop can be stronger than the
cooperation between rook and Knight so I
I think taking with the real well
actually the move let's play that it was
move 40 you take out four so both
players now have an extra half hour in
the pock and these situations are
sometimes tricky it's to cool down after
someone intense time situation and now
let's see if has time to calculate the
position has changed drastically and now
it's going to be a whole new battle
what's going on here given the the
imbalance pawn structure given Bishop
versus Knight scenario
when I see this chances when I see the
future of the white rook to go to be one
be seven and together with the bishop to
you and the pawn coming with a v e6 I
think white is the favorite one here I
would have to choose White's just given
given the potential in the position but
sometimes these positions are easy to or
it may be easy to evaluate but not
always easy to play
given that okay you have to be somewhat
accurate the might can be very tricky
especially when it's centralized we
might see some eventual move from black
like c5 to cement the knight on d4 and
this pawn on f4 for the time being it's
a pretty strong passed pawn why can't
easily win it the knight is supporting
this f3 square so we might see f3 player
that's um at some point
meanwhile blacks King could walk in as
well so it's not maybe not so easy as as
we originally thought for whites so most
likely vas if he's gonna take his time
here finally is happy to make me for day
or maybe you may play soon anyway I
would switch gears to to the game black
universe and Daenerys Arkansas others
another endgame rogue Bishop rook Bishop
but why it seems to have some very
strong pawns going for promotion has now
this position takes a moment for me to
absorb what's what's going on but as I'm
realizing like these pawns just seem
unstoppable like what is dinar we're
gonna do about a six or be six coming
next especially with this rook on d7
seems just about hopeless for black I
mean we can know that the bone on g3 is
kind of advance the pawn on e5 may be
coming but that seems too slow I really
don't see any hope for the black side
here but maybe we can have some fun and
player doubts the one move that comes to
mind is Bishop th4 with idea of rogue f6
and rook F to okay so let's say I you
move
v6 so b6r got six and now I'm
threatening wrote F - okay you know what
I started with a six AHA a six making
sure that the pawn is on the a file not
the D file I will still go for the same
idea
seven seven rook F 2 kg one King do you
won okay I'll take your visit yeah and
then I'll check and I have only move Kim
G - G - rugby - I'm just hoping for some
vertical here so I will go probably King
h3 it's three G - oh you can even play
Queen takes you to but now I also have
King f8 for queen of fate and we have a
result for the game Sergei my tango
against Vladimir Bellas
no no against Emile I'm gonna drag then
that is a draw so we're gonna have
Camille the winner of Group B in the
studio very shortly
maybe nothing to play for either side I
mean B we did think that certainly was
the favorite one but Queen traded yeah
this seems like like the cetera I mean
coming a very great tournament no law
says only wins and draws yeah it seemed
like Sergei was maybe the one playing
for a win at some points but Queens did
get traded and I think this game maybe
supports the point that all of our kinks
are drawn but congratulations Camille
finishing the tournament with a very
solid game and I'll be interesting to
hear his thoughts about how he was able
to kind of cope throughout the term into
to win a very strong event like this and
also what did he think about like b6
move because I thought it was a very
nice idea of Sergei that was certainly a
nice idea yeah so let's uh let's move on
let's stay with the games which are
still going you want to go back to the
turn our game yeah I see some changes
the bishops are traded b6 happened
so either the game will be over soon or
we have a rogue and game everything
rough so because all
work endings are drawn I'm trying to
find the game but it disappeared from me
oh okay here it is
so the Bishop's did get traded how did
that happen so let's get it back let's
see well first of all Queens got traded
Oden our play efore so going for the
advance of the past a pawn this also
seems pretty hopeless just b6 played
what to do in this position I mean let's
see b6 the I mean the pawns racing down
the board on the Queen side for white
and is there any sort of counter play
for black here I mean the pawn on e4
doesn't seem to have too much hope but
maybe we can speculate okay some line
like III but white could even play
something like rookie 7 attack the pawn
in e3 what is black doing in this
position e to roped a key - no this is
just this just seems lost for for black
in this position if we refresh the
boards to the current position dinara is
thinking here she has 25 minutes to to
ponder if you want weren't wrong in the
game but really not too much to hope for
from this position so I think a lot of
the games are done we do have okay we
see Donora they're thinking we still
have the Sam 7 against vicita or Bailey
battle in Group A but we'll be set very
shortly for an interview with Camille
dragon the winner of Group B let me find
that game here
I'll see Camille dragon well before I
find the game I think I can find Camille
in the studio welcome Camille and
congratulations on a very impressive
results Thank You Claire first what were
your thoughts coming into the day I mean
you there was some possibility if you've
lost your game
and andrey zhuk open won his game that
there would be a playoff where you may
be worried about that scenario or what
was your psychology not very much I was
pretty confident after really some games
I was more and more confident during the
tournament because I started playing
better I think after some first mm-hmm
and I know you were playing someone who
you've you've probably gotten to know
over the last several days sir game on
cinco you were you were roommates with
during the tournament we were maybe in
the commentary studio we were expecting
a quick draw in this game but were you
the one playing for the win with Sergei
playing for a win it was a bit hard to
tell
I think Sergei was playing for a win it
was he wanted to improve his score and
for me there was enough to win the
tournament so I was happy withdrawn fair
enough I mean that makes perfect sense
for you take us through the game it
seemed like a somewhat unusual opening
this this idea very early on 96 which
you don't see too often the night going
in front of the the c-pawn was this
something that you prepared yeah it's
quite rare but I'm saying it's some from
time to time just to surprise my
opponent fair enough and I do want to go
forward to the the middle game position
it was seemed very imbalanced and seemed
like maybe you were under some pressure
yeah here looked at after exchanging
Conde - he has some advantage but it's
not so easy after career I think Queen
b6 was a good move there Queen b6 team
should maybe just stabilize position I
think I four was also the best and
through cavity itis I don't want to do
this move I would prefer to play a rope
88 but there is this opposite free
always they should c3 with this apron
being a potential target in position
yeah that's the problem of Queen on b6
that I cannot play physics and
working but I was always little too late
like everything was hanging there Bishop
on g2 was attacking b7 no I just seemed
like white had so much better harmony
with the pieces than you you had to kind
of do what you needed to do to hold on
to the position yeah maybe here d5 was
interesting but after d5 I always play
e5 and I tried to close the position and
after that my plan is Queen c7 b6 might
be if he wants to play like he has to
play like he falleth want to play at 4
but maybe I can counter him like by him
f5 I was considering it yeah would be an
interesting line yeah first probably
Queen c7 to definitely she satisfied if
I prefer 76 to the photography and after
that maybe I would think about that 5 I
see
so going back to what happened in the
game I mean it seemed like it just had
to take it like a few moves for back to
consolidate the position yeah if I fizz
like very tricky I I already wanted to
play Bishop f8 Bishop f8 in this
position or in this position in this
position yeah almost but I realized that
if I was interesting because this this
looks like after d5 there was like I
told that I have a trick it did Bishop
d5 be show before but unfortunately
there is Bishop a7
bishop take f7 king together and queen
if for coming out for and then winning
back the piece yeah so we opted for
safer variation after b75 like I have to
play like I do want to interrupt you for
a moment
Palace did defeat to Nara said you a
cassava so not the best performance
overall for Bellus but he did have a
nice win in the final round
yeah I think he had very nice ending of
the tournament he won two last games
yeah sometimes yesterday he drove Oh
yesterday he drew so but sometimes you
have the momentum shift or maybe a surge
in motivation to place another chess
let's stick with this game I do want to
get to the moment it was this
interesting moment where white went for
this b6 move preventing you from playing
musics was this something that you were
expecting yeah I was calculating this
line but I wasn't sure that he can play
like that but it appeared that he can
because he some time to take on c5
always right and just seemed like
perhaps a trader pawns trying to lead
slightly better endgame for whites yeah
I think this was his only shines because
if I would be able to play B six myself
I don't have problems at all
exactly and G 4 was here very
interesting I didn't expect this move g4
seems to come out of nowhere it makes it
very short I talked about B so quite
afraid here instead of what you for like
to have after exchanging constancy 5
everything to not allow me to play
Bishop e8 because there will be hanging
on that five I see but I wanted to play
here King kept seven but maybe here g4
or taking one c5
for everything we can take everything
and at the end I have concur six I see I
should be fine here so yeah it seems a
bit tricky is I mean it's not easy for a
white to get a clear advantage in these
lines going forward what happened in the
game after the forest getting like very
messy I didn't know what to do it was
already time to about so and what's your
psychology knowing that you like you
already won the event
and you still have a game to play and
it's unclear how do you just focus on
playing the game and not just sit back
and relax and then accept your your your
your money it's like very bad feelings
to win the tournament but to slow the
game so I didn't need like extra
motivations for sure okay so oh that's
good that you're just motivated by like
just by playing your chest not by make
the external factors yeah it's like the
same is when you are doing like very
buddy in the tournament and but you you
in like two tools games it's always like
like for Vladimir I'm sure that he feels
much better now I understand yeah so
going forward it seemed like things
simplified yeah after Queen c5 through
Pietro create focus if I throw key three
or a five
we're sorry is this a line that happened
the game or this is no no after because
instead of 26 maybe I could take what it
was like unpleasant to defend this row
King yeah we were actually looking at
some line might be at all I don't know
maybe it's not just not necessary to go
into yeah Queen just six it was like
octave today so yeah like we we admired
this move given that White's King is
less safe and we were thinking maybe
even black could play for something
given the weaknesses and whites pawns
yeah I was thinking maybe that maybe I'm
fighting for right because if he doesn't
break if he doesn't exchange the Queen's
I will have utter some kind of attack at
least absolutely so yeah Queen d4 and
then at this point after rook to e3 I
just in very Josh yeah the rookies
yeah going for it so final position yeah
I think wendy6 was better practical try
mm-hmm yeah well well nice finish for
you congratulations again I mean what
does it mean for you winning a
tournament like this I'm sure getting
some nice prize fund or prize money and
gaining some rating points what are your
what are your future plans going into
the summer I'm going tomorrow to Chicago
and for Chicago open and after that I'm
going back to my country to Poland for
the vacation but it's very nice I was
able to win this tournament because I I
wasn't confident before the tournament
at all because I didn't practice much I
didn't play much like I placed I think
only couple games in this year so it's
like I wanted to just remind how to play
chess by playing here and in Chicago but
it was I'm surprised I mean sometimes it
just comes down to the mental form that
you have during an event and it seemed
like you were very unformed some very
beautiful games so congratulations and
best of luck over the summer yeah thank
you you're welcome
and with that we're going to take a
quick break and we'll be back with more
coverage and again congratulations to
Group B champion Grand Master Camille
dragon
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenged them
to a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with chess 24 Premium Membership this
August the best chess players in the
world are coming to st. Louis for the
grand chest tour
st. Louis rapid and blitz and
Sinquefield Cup tournaments will feature
the world's best right here in st. Louis
st. Louis Chess Club is celebrating its
10th anniversary and these tournaments
will be a highlight you won't want to
miss for tickets and more information go
to st. Louis chess club org
there's a weekend vacation on one tank
trip in a nearby city you won't wanna
skip
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
welcome back everyone to the 2018 summer
chess classic I'm international master
Eric Rosen joined back with the women's
Grand Master Katerina Lenova
welcome back Katerina thank you we had a
very good great game I actually just
talked to Sergey my thing go upstairs
and he said it he was very happy I mean
he thought he's okay after Queen g6 and
maybe playing for when coming over
saying he's playing for a win in that
position that's very interesting to see
both their masters being happy with the
same position I mean that's what we want
to see towards the end of the tournament
especially given the situation Camille
was happy with a draw but when he's he's
playing for win himself we know it's
it's more entertaining for the viewers
and it just leads to a better finish for
everyone so let's move on to the last
game of the tournament and a crucial
game massive durable e against Sam
Savion they're both playing for playoff
or maybe Vasi for the win in the
tournament that's right and this is the
only game remaining between the two
groups
a lot on the line on this game if the
Seif wins he just clinches first but if
Sam drawers or wins then there will be a
playoff involving version of Cobian so
but let's get to the current position
Sam has has lunged forward with this
move pawn f3 and I'm curious in this
position is this pong enough 3 is it a
strength or a weakness and the king can
come to g3 the bishop can come to e4 it
looks like it's a lot more weak than it
is strong given that white has a
potential to attack the pawn with all of
his pieces but surprisingly we have a
roof and rest of a thief played through
b1 to g1 interesting idea not going for
the pawn but going for some rook g6 idea
and possibly even a rogue f6 so rook g6
work ethics maybe going for the rook
trade very interesting idea because the
idea is if the rooks are out and we do
get the white King Khan III then we are
attacking the knight and attacking the
pawn so let's just see let's say black
play something like a 5
some waiting with rook to g6 King h5 the
king of course doesn't want to go to h7
given a plethora of discovery checks so
King h5 would need to be played I see an
interesting option here that white can
actually try to play Ruby g7 and go for
a tricky
checkmate on 87 how does black stop the
techniques good question okay that's
such a sad move it seems like the thief
should be very happy here given the
rekon h8 completely passive piece maybe
a simple move like King to g3 and it
just seems like black is stuck it's a
nice idea or we can play even rook F
seven instead of King g3 and we have to
keep in mind that the king is still
trapped I mean the root cannot move from
h8 because there would always be the
checkmate on 87 so this seems like a
winning position so black has to be
careful about such threat so rook g1 may
be actually a very strong tool I really
like this move from of a thief and Sam
has played relatively quick F to perhaps
calculating the variations rook one of
two played and now White has a potential
for rook g6 check in the position we
should note that black will be
threatening to Queen with Chuck so maybe
this is mating ideas won't be so quick
but we still can go Ruby g6 and root f6
major works so Luke g6 happened now we
are expecting king h5 because King h6
would be probably big blunder we should
attack we should note that the thief
does have repetition if he wants it he
can just repeat with rook g5 rook h6
river of g6 and the king is is just
forced to move back and forth on the H
file so now it's a question is Wasif
playing for more in this position so if
he makes the draw he is securing his
spot in the playoff if he continues he
may play for when to go for a career
first that's right what are you reading
for counter unit you want to see a
playoff or do you want to see a clear
champion well when I look at this
position I feel that after rook f6 black
white is keeping an advantage
so I don't see the reason to to go for
for a draw it makes a lot of sense and a
line like rook f6 rook takes pawn take
f6 weights doing a very good job at kind
of blocking like the black king out of
out of being able to attack the white
pawn given that white is controlling
these key squares it's kind of like a
wall that that the black king can't
really penetrate and meanwhile White has
ideas of not only pawn f7 but also just
king g2 and in going after that after
you fought so it doesn't look like what
is risking anything with the rook trait
but maybe maybe we can keep the rooks on
board and try to do something something
more than just looking I don't know is
there anything else we can do besides
rogue g5 and rook f6 well we see yeah we
just saw the see if he reached out his
hand it looked like he touched his rook
when he brought his hand back now he's
it's doing this post now going back to
the classic chess player thinking close
Sam scratching his head as he walks away
from the board
the Cephas perhaps realizing that he has
time to use in this position he wants to
be extra sure on whatever move he's he
plays that it's the right decision going
back to the current position I wouldn't
be surprised if he maybe repeats once
plays rook g5 forces King h6 and then
decides if he wants to play for more but
I think we can expect the eventual
rift at six that's a good idea a good
strategy to start with the pretending
that we want to repeat the position just
to say that we are the one who can have
draw at any moment and then we can
deviate and play something else to see
just often this the one who's actually
worse in that position this this video
gives me anxiety like the see if it's
reaching across the board almost making
a movement pulling his hand back when is
he actually gonna make a move seems like
there's a lot of tension in the room
even though it's only game going and now
we see is he actually gonna make a move
he made a move rook to f6 so he is going
for the route trade and he wants the
summit endgame rook again I mean bishop
against Knight
with some chances that's right and both
players pretty equal on time receive
about 20 minutes Sam just just over 21
minutes and okay Sam appears to have
traded the rooks for C free capturing on
our six brings us to the current
position Oh Sam has already touched the
Queen do you see that Sam just picked up
the Queen and brought it to the side so
do you think he's going to promote I
mean that's an idea to play f1 here
let's try to play everyone to promote a
queen forcing the bishop to recapture it
and then having King g6 so let's take
taking g6 attacking the opponent f6 and
just taking it back so it's a short-term
sacrifice where we actually just
recapture opponent very quickly but it's
did good now it's interesting to mention
that we have a pawn on the H file but
which is promoting on dark square so if
the pawn on f6 is going to be taken and
the pawn on a4 is going to be out this
is just a draw that's a very good point
and we might see this play out I would
like to just demonstrate the line let's
say say white activates the King King g4
King take f6 so he like goes for the H
pawn push and then all that needs to do
if I'm not mistaken a sacrifice tonight
for the pawn and that shouldn't be too
difficult perhaps a move like 96 going
for a knight c5 let's say white plays
some some sort of waiting move like
Bishop to e2 the knight can attack the
pawn and I can continue to attack the
pawn and then after we move like Knight
c5 this seems like a dead draw after
Knight take a 6 bishop take a 6 for
those who don't know your your general
basic end games there's no way to win
this position as white given the the
queening squares on a dark square and
white only has the light square bishop
so all that needs to do is just goes to
the corner and
so it looks like we're gonna have a
playoff yeah if the games drawing its
received er Bailey against fusion a
Cobian we can see the Seif thinking in
this position trying to see if there is
any winning chances but I I don't see
any and I think I would be very
surprised if you can muster up anything
in this position so what if we reviewed
the player format that the players may
play because it's a it's a very
interesting way to decide who's gonna be
the winner in the tournament that's
right I mean at this point I think we
can expect Wasif Terra Bailey against
version of Kobe in if there is a playoff
it will be a two-game rapid match ten
minutes per side with a two-second delay
and if the match is tied one to one then
it goes to Armageddon and we recently
saw Armageddon in the US Women's
Championship very exciting playoff
between naazy pickins e and annie
weighing the format for that game white
having extra time five minutes plus two
second increments black having less time
at four minutes plus you say second
increment but having draw outs so I'm
sure I'm sure that will be very exciting
if we get to that but there's still a
long ways to go and there is no
guarantee for Armageddon if if we see a
winner in the two-game rapid match I'm
curious what do you think Vasi if or VAR
would pick a scholar for the Armageddon
game because we know that Vasa is very
aggressive he would probably pick white
but I'm not sure about what var would
pick because he can play strategically
try to hold on to the draw with black
pieces suggestions no I agree that the
thief would pick white
so actually given VARs opening repertory
the thief has an e4 player Farah plays a
lot of a lot of openings are fun to
attack against like the French defense
or the Pirates if you've even seen like
some Carroll cons from him so I think if
yeah if a thief was white or if I see if
could choose White's he would I wouldn't
be surprised if fr would choose black
given that if we saw the game early in
the tournament
var played the thief with the white
pieces and var got no advance
Jancy Greenfeld and VAR has told me
multiple times it's so hard to get in
managing its Infeld sigh I think both
sides the Seif would be happy with white
part would be happy with black so again
there's a perfect solution both planners
are happy with their choices and I'm
going to fight for the first end of the
day only one player will be happy and
we'll have to wait and see so let's go
back to the game see if something
happened I see king g6
so black is going for the f6 pawn Massey
is just holding his hat I'm not sure if
his I'm looking for tricks in this
position I was tempted to play something
like h5 I'm realizing this doesn't work
at all because after a king day gage v
f7 the knight can come back to East 6 so
sometimes in these positions you want to
look for tricks but the tricks which
exists just don't seem to be doing
anything and I mean blacks plan just
seems so simple so I look for him to
talk to actually were safe to see I mean
we talked about the DeMuth rubgy - that
he played and taken it on h4 and going
into this end game if he saw it or maybe
if he missed f1 and he didn't see this
trait how to get into this draw position
yeah I mean it seemed like the thief was
the one playing for something and we did
like this this rook g1 idea I think the
problem is is sound very easily was able
to simplify I am curious if if a thief
realized this line was work with rook f6
was a draw maybe he should have ended
the game more quickly with with the
repetition and save some power afford a
playoff yeah because at this point I
mean energy conservation is really
important to reiterate it is it is just
after 310 here in st. Louis if there is
a playoff
it starts at least half hour after this
last game finishes I think the latest it
can start is 5 p.m.
we'll have to get confirmation on that
going forward in position there have
been some moves played Sam did capture
the pawn enough six going back to after
King g6 King g4 was played and current
position moves are coming out pretty
quickly here Sam opted for for Knight to
f5 I'm sorry wait what happened I see 95
being played and Bishop i6o Bishop c4
was played and then Knight f5 and then
Bishop a6 so again I mean all all black
has to do sacrifice the nights for the a
pawn but perhaps easier said than done
so the trick is it's very interesting so
black has to make a move now and kimchi
six for example would be a big blunder
because White has a trig here very nice
resource Bishop d3 pinning tonight and
getting denied for free so King g6 is
not a possible move so what else black
can do but I can move the knight maybe
give a check on e3 I would be very
tempted to move the knight maybe just
reposition it to a square like d5 yeah
93 check looks very logical make White's
King moved to a less active square
should mention if King f4 is played it
would give black extra tempi to to come
closer to winning the pawn some maybe a
move like King f3 but it just seems like
black black should have no trouble
drawing this position and we have a move
Sam decided to play 94 so he did not
choose check but he is repositioning the
knight to a different square
I mean 94 19 no Center controlling many
squares it cannot be a bad choice 94 and
then King h5 played seems a bit unusual
to put the King in front of the pawn but
maybe the thief is trying to create a
situation where he can slowly march up
the King in the pawn but then at some
point I feel like his King was just
gonna get stuck I mean it's a very nice
idea so he wants to prevent black for
being able to capture with night upon on
a4 and getting the King to the center
so he wants to like make a body check
for the King to go away
secure the pawn on each file and maybe
try for something but it's unclear it
looks like the king is logged there and
blood should be able to hold to a draw I
have a question here what if black goes
for a completely different idea in the
position and just sacrifices a knight
for the Aged pawn and then just runs
with the King tries to win the 8th on
that have any merits like a move maybe
like north at 5 just go after this pawn
age and h4 because blacks king will be
closer to the the Queen side so that's a
nice nice idea resemble King g4 and I
ticket for maybe it's a bit too risky
but it looks playable I'm sure it would
require calculation it's probably not at
all necessary it's just an idea in
position but the interesting idea is
also if white wants to let's say play
Bishop e7 and pushed up on all the way
to a6 I believe that's a draw when we
get the King on b8 with black mm
actually I think you're right
I would just like to show that position
let's imagine yeah Bishop to d7 let's
say the King walks in let's say pawn
gets to a6 black goes here White's King
gets back in playing a bunch of moves
here but this is a this is a pretty well
known endgame where even though the pawn
is on the or has the right cleaning
Square there's no way for a white to
actually make progress in this position
have you have an onion like this before
yes I had an endgame that's why I
remember that I was actually the one who
had the bishop so it was a little sad I
tried to move around to win the game but
it's just I do want to show there is one
way for a white to win this position
I've actually shown this exact endgame
to a number of students and it's it's a
really funny way to win I actually
witnessed this this way of winning
happening in a tournament it was like a
high school tournament players where
maybe below below
1600 but it's a really funny way for a
white to win let's imagine both sides
are in time pressure they just have to
play some quick moves actually King g6
is still me let's not stop looking I'll
say the bishop moves here came here at
check here so the strategy for white is
to get the bishop controlling this long
diagonal and just make blacks King move
back and forth and the game that I
witnessed many years ago white played
very you know in the very clever manner
he just moved his bishop along this
diagonal making sure black was in the
habit of moving back and forth with the
king and many more moves was work played
out both sides were just playing off
delay and at the in the game and then at
the right moment white shifted the
bishop to this diagonal its f3 and black
was so used to moving the King back and
forth he played the move King a8 and
then out of nowhere King c7 checkmate
and it's not an idea that you see so
often but it applies for this position
so even if you got this position you
have to be somewhat awake as a black
player yeah that's a great example like
reminding ourselves how much awake we
have to be throughout the whole game
because one move can decide the whole
game you can play very well and then at
the end after 40 moves of playing around
you just miss this opportunity you don't
play King c8
you play a wrong move King 8 and you get
checkmate it
yeah it's sad for the black player to
suffer this but that's why you you
constantly have to be aware of your
opponent's play you can never get so
relaxed in this situation black just got
relaxed moving back and forth and then
then got severely punished for it let's
go back to the game let's see if there's
any anything happening a few more moves
have been played Bishop to d3 and then
96 let's go back to earlier I don't
think this has been too eventful just
some dancing around with the minor
pieces and it's still a question like
what is white doing here I wouldn't be
surprised of Sam maybe just goes for the
the C pawn advance and extra pawn
doesn't
maybe isn't too significant in the
position but perhaps Sam can use it as a
nuisance for a way to deal with anything
white plate of ossified King h5 again
trying to force the King to the corner
Sam responded pretty quickly with King
g7
kingi sudden solid moves from from Sam
making sure white skin can advance up
the board and I mean meanwhile what to
do for white black is just waiting
around white can try to play let's say
King g5 here q g5 looks like that's what
was played see mycommerce photobomb
their brief moment so Sam responded with
97 do you see how Sam move the knight to
b7 it was like so calm just with a flick
of the wrist I mean here's a pretty nice
idea he really wants to go to c5 I
tagged Adobe shop grab the pawn even if
it's a sacrifice on a4 then move just
King h8 and offer draw exactly and okay
it seems like a forcing line now that
both players play incredibly quickly
Knight c5 Bishop to c2 and now at any
point Sam can just take the pawn they
deponent offer a draw I mean versiv
would probably agree at this moment
because there is nothing you can do you
have the wrong square on the last place
a5 not taking Mathon but h6 check played
forcing blacks King into the corner
moves coming out very rapidly here I
think both players just know it's a draw
just a matter of getting the job done
King to f6 played
Sam did not take the pawn again 9:27 I
mean he can take the pawn whenever he
wants but I'm curious what is this
psychological game happening here I mean
just grab the pawn offer draw game over
King f7 played I mean this is Sam's
final game it's gonna end in the trough
sounds gonna be over with the tournament
but if I see if is gonna have to have at
least two more games of chess ahead of
him very important games to okay we see
Sam play tonight c5 and then King g6
just take the pawn and just do it again
he doesn't have to but not sure not sure
how this is gonna end you think he's
gonna take the pawn I do you think he's
gonna just keep down I really don't
understand what's happening here
sometimes when you see such a game you
think that maybe the player does not
understand that he can take the pawn and
make a draw but I'm sure some - so he
maybe just doesn't want to give up the
piece he's saying like it's a draw
anyway and I don't I'm not the weaker
side here so I'm not gonna sacrifice
anything how exactly I mean why not why
not keep the Knights I mean if he can
take the pawn any time I'm surprised
neither player is offering a draw I feel
like if I were to see if in this
position I mean okay it's going to be a
draw
just take the draw and then focus on the
playoff King f6 played maybe a position
is going to be here Kim G's expect King
g8
yeah maybe repetition is most likely but
we couldn't see both these players
incredibly fighting players they just
they're there fighting and fighting and
fighting and like the last thing they
wanted to withdraw the game it's gonna
happen at some point though I like how
Sam is now very focused thinking he has
24 minutes I hope he's not gonna spend
24 minutes thinking on the smooth oh oh
that would be Jana that would be
terrible for everyone but okay maybe now
he's considering taking the pawn I'm not
sure if there's any difference or he
could just keep dancing with the knight
but see if they're drinking some tea
Jackie shaking fog
it is 3:21 p.m. st. Louis time Sam
taking a sip of water there seemed like
he said something but maybe not maybe is
just swallowing the water now now we see
the classic pose from from Sam it is
interesting to know that the playoff may
start sooner than 5 p.m. if the players
are both in the house here and agreed to
to start sooner that's that is a good
point and I don't believe that we're
gonna be cutting out the broadcast so
everyone who's watching us so far can
continue watching what we will have
maybe an extended break at some points
but we will be checking the YouTube chat
so if you guys want to say hi to us if
you have questions for us feel free make
yourself heard in the YouTube chat we
see some some viewers who are active
here shout out to Cognito and Kane
Thomas and Isaac France a lot of fans
here good to see you all
anything happen a few more moves have
been played but I'm really no progress
being made for either side so there's a
progress we do have a pond on 8 7 it's
almost close to promote but the king is
on h8 blocking it so will the players
decide to make a draw some passive looks
like ok the game is over let's let's
make a draw but Sam is like no I want to
think very hard nothing Sam does
night nights can be tricky we've we've
seen that before but I mean okay what
did you tonight if he doesn't want to
take the pawn I guess he could move he
could play something like 96 I I hope
he's gonna just take it upon just take
the pawn place e5 push the pawns get all
the pawns captured it's a stalemate
afterwards maybe we can show that line
that looks like it's something
interesting the pawn yeah and then black
just give up the rest of the pawns and
as a white you can play the very simple
Bishop a two forces tell me at one move
earlier and even extra even if the
players would like to continue the
arbiter would come here and say okay
guys it's a draw you can actually play
more I'm sure they would love to play a
lot and here it is he's taking the pawn
Hey
so maybe we'll see those still may play
out so I know in these situations I
usually play it out I mean why not just
to show the viewers of is he's playing
incredibly enthusiastically there and
they shake hands like Hummer they're
collecting the score sheets kudos to my
comer I don't think there's been any any
issues or any controversies this event
like Hummer I believe he's a chief
arbiter for this event and there's gonna
be more work for Mike to do later on
with a play-off looming so it's gonna be
the C star Bailey against version
dacovian who's your pick to win the
event that's a very hard question I mean
these players they know each other very
well we have to know that vasudevaya
he's studying at Webster University and
here in st. louis farrakhan he lives
here in st. Louis so they probably met
on various occasions I feel like I don't
know I'm probably I don't want to pick
it I don't know I want to see how the
first game is going who it's gonna
actually have white I think the player
that may start with white pieces can
have an advantage because you start
pushing
and I think psychologically that can be
good for for the white player mm-hmm
we see the safe and sound perhaps
discussing the game sure there are many
moments in that game which they want to
go back and check with the engine given
that it seemed like flex should have
been better earlier but it didn't have
the breakthrough then it seemed like the
thief was better towards the end game
but didn't have any clear way of
converting the advantage so the last
round of tournament a is over let's
review the results yeah we had some a
series of results today I'm not sure if
we have a graphic for it
we do have standings for today in Group
A we see version of Kobe and the CCR
Bailey tied for first place
Sam Savion just missing the tie
finishing and clear third place still a
very good result for Sam very nice to
Raman so let's see now the results of a
groupie yeah as we mentioned earlier a
Camille dragon finishing and clear first
in Group B congratulations Camille
well played tournament if we take a look
at what happened today there were two
decisive games both Vladimir Bellis
defeating subdue a cassava and Alejandra
Ramirez defeating a good friend talked
of a Brahmin feel bad for Tata losing to
losing to a friend it's not maybe the
most pleasant way to finish an event and
I just see that only the two female
players lost in this round for a groupie
that's definitely not something I'm
happy to see but what can we do I mean
chess is a hard game so let's see what
are the standings for a group P we do
not have a playoff here camel dragon the
polish Grandmaster is the winner of
Group B followed by androids to copying
and we have a tie for the second third
place where JJ Ali Miranda and Robert
agus re on both have five points yeah
it's uh I mean lots of money will be
taken home this event and it was great
to see so many exciting games of chess
and we're gonna stick around even longer
for at least two more games a rapid
playoff I've been saying since the
beginning and this tournament that we're
always looking for it to the playoff
I know it's finally happened
it's gonna be very exciting to to see
how players are handling this the
situation but we do want to know that
the Grantchester is also about to start
next month in Belgium in levan followed
by ramen in Paris that's right and then
of course in August we have two amazing
events coming to st. Louis from August
9th to 16th we have the st. Louis rapid
and blitz incredibly exciting event and
it's amazing for for spectators to come
here in person so many super
grandmasters last year Kasparov came out
of retirement to play the event not sure
if he's coming back this year probably
not but it's filling me some very high
quality rapid and speed chess and
following this event we have the sixth
annual Sinquefield Cup the part of
Grantchester is the only tournament that
has classical chess the players it's not
it confirmed who is gonna participate we
can make only predictions but it's
always a very strong tournament it's
great to watch the a surgeon and Maurice
will be back for this another exciting
event too to watch or be present here
that's right and be sure to follow all
the action on grand chess to or.org I
think right now we're gonna take an
extended break and be back with the
playoff we'll be back in 30 minutes or
less so stay tuned a moment comes in
chess when you need to test yourself at
a different level chess 24 premium
offers the tools that you need to reach
your maximum potential from hundreds of
interactive video lessons to becoming
part of the chess 24 community you can
analyze with friends or coach your
students live you get twenty four by
seven coverage of chest news and events
access to premium analysis and
commentary and the chance to interact
with grandmasters and other top players
and coaches get it bashed from the best
and even challenge them to a battle be
the best chess player you can be it's
time to level up your game with just 24
Premium Membership
this is a crucial situation in this game
Metheny must make a move but what will
it be all eyes are on the theme to make
a move a lot easier if you weren't doing
that right next to me it doesn't bother
me check the st. Louis chess club
celebrating 10 years of promoting
teaching and playing the game of chess
visit the st. Louis chess club and help
celebrate our 10th anniversary
there's a weekend vacation on one tank
trip in a nearby city you won't wanna
skip so much pop for your family
[Music]
a question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like PA 3
is an illegal move here because white
masters pawn to square is not one but it
still is something we call on person and
you can do that you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move like
let's say clay King in seven kimchi -
and now try because y'all played four
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed at length during the course of
my stay
yeah he told me this is excellent g5
this was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think we find this one
Noah Lawrence this is not how chess
works certainly would be much much more
fun if chess actually work like this I
don't think it does how maybe it does
well that's me regretting what I just
said how did I get from there to here is
a little bit beyond me and what's worse
I will never hear the end of it my
quality of life has just gone downhill
tremendously because I'm actually
sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
this August the best chess players in
the world are coming to st. Louis for
the grand chest tour
st. Louis rapid and blitz and
Sinquefield Cup tournaments will feature
the world's best right here in st. Louis
st. Louis Chess Club is celebrating its
10th anniversary and these tournaments
will be a highlight you won't want to
miss for tickets and more information go
to st. Louis chess club org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back we are
having playoff for the group one group a
vez if durable is playing Vera Cobian
they drew lot
what happened Erik that's right it looks
like the thief has the black pieces
against far in the first game now we
should keep in mind this is a two-game
rapid playoff and if they're tied one to
one after the first game it comes down
to Armageddon so let's see they have two
rounds to play both 10 minutes var is
having white for the first round
I told ma that may be an advantage yeah
we should also know it for has kind of
the advantage when it comes to just
physical energy has a very quick draw in
the last round today and I mean the
sieve had a very long game against Sam 7
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
playoff format just to clarify what
what's taking place there is a two-game
rapid match both sides having 10 minutes
with a two second delay and if the match
is Thai that's Armageddon with white
having extra time 5 minutes plus a 2
second increments black having four
minutes with increments and draw odds so
I'm sure sure will be looking forward to
under Gavin if it gets to that stage so
the game is starting in five seconds so
let's take a look
the players are ready shaking hands and
var is about to start
it's like fart making sure the clock was
actually started there and some moves
being played very quickly looks like
we're gonna see a green felled we saw a
green felled being played in many games
as tournaments with far having the white
side of this each playing mini groove
green fells is black and we do have it I
see d5 there Greenfeld is happening and
now a virus thinking what to do he's
capturing on d5 so he may go for the
main line here it is nine takes e 3.8
see three moves coming in very rapidly
it's a bit hard to keep up but looks
like we have the main line position of
our paused for a moment played Knights
f3 and now Plan C 5 still in theoretical
waters after a Bishop to e3 Queen a5
Queen d2 neither of us are Greenfeld
experts so I can't give too much
commentary
this line but I'm pretty sure just based
on the speed the players are playing I
mean just double click to display
Greenfeld about three times in a
classical game but then I decided to
drop the opening it was a little too
passive for me but I was looking at
they're still in theory of course castle
yeah the the the online board is having
a hard time catching up to the physical
port so many moves being played
I think certainly there is a pause for
just playing kini to Bishop d7 I mean I
see if it's playing logical mostly shall
be seven now connecting the rooks maybe
now rook d8 following development so
viral is launching an attack h4 maybe he
wants to play h5 and break on the Kings
side seems like a very positional battle
I'm sure both both far and the sea if
we're expecting some kind of line like
this see if still playing very quickly
it rook F to c8 we should note the C
file is the only open file on board so
both players probably want to think
about doubling up but we do see some
space advantage for white in this
position I mean these pawns on on e5 and
d4 seem a bit menacing and it leaves
black's bishop on g7 bit out of the play
in the position and we also talked about
the bishop being on the same color and
Bishop on d7 is just staring at its own
pawn on e6 the good part for black is
that black has advantage on the Queen
side with the pole on b7 and a 6 but
many moves are coming so 9595 Farah
going after this potential target on e6
attacked by both the knight and the
bishop and Vasile is forced to retreat
98 not the most aesthetically pleasing
move and then Barba treated the Bishop
to b3 perhaps increasing some tension
along the C file but maybe that's reason
why vas if chose rook F to see it so I
have this 90 98 while the rooks are
still connected so I mean it looks
passive but but I can't just trade the
rooks and try to maybe move the pawns on
the Queen side that's a good point
whenever there's only one open file in
the position you want your
to be connected so you can fight for
that one open file after Bishop III it's
for seefs move and now it's the first
moment where he's actually taking time
to figure out what's going on perhaps
he's out of his opening preparation and
needs to come up with his own plans one
move that pops out right out right away
is just a simple h6 just kick the night
away and relieve the pressure on on e6
an H has just happened that was played
in vara very quickly retreats the Knight
to h3 looking to go to f4 - to keep the
pressure so now another move that makes
sense it's either to improve the knight
improve the King or maybe trade the
rocks yeah maybe some some options for
receive the seif would really like to
expand further with g5 but the current
currently is off limits he decided to
trade on c1 practice going for a
simplification and now after rook c8 we
can see all the routes come off the
board and when the rooks are off its I
mean there are delight pieces and
they're well plays they are doing okay
are we pretty doing draw here I mean I'm
sure the thief would be very happy with
withdrawing the first rapid game that
would give him white in the second game
and everything to play for it
yeah that's it's possible that that if
the rook gets the rooks do you get
traded it is maybe it's a bit easier to
draw up I feel I still feel like White
has a push in the position with this
Knight coming to f4
so maybe white can take on c8 let's just
see rook takes a display so take c8 and
now white can go with Knight f4 maybe to
make a transfer with the night to night
d3 and Knight c5 yeah lots of potential
for the night he chose a completely
different plan playing pawn f4 maybe
someone unexpected but perhaps enabling
the maneuver at night f2 to d3 where the
night does have some long-term potential
especially if it can get to c5 it could
put a lot of pressure against Blacks
pawn structure and also the f4 point is
defending the opponent
five so we have the future with pushing
the d5 pawn and maybe allowing the
light-square bishop to control more
squares on the board I do have to say
I'm not impressed with box pieces look
at look at all of Box minor pieces both
bishops being pretty sad in the position
not doing anything to help black out and
it's not on g8 incredibly passive so the
thief seems like he has some untangling
to do
he just started with the move Bishop to
f8 seems like the only reasonable
diagonal for the bishop so now at least
it's not staring at White's very
well-supported punching in the center
and another idea that black can do here
is to play Bishop d7 Bishop c6 and get
the bishop on the diagonal attacking the
pawn g2 and I see it just had it just
has what was played yet Bishop to g7
some logical moves from the sieve just
looking to improve the bishops and it
looks like far lunch for it with the
move pawn d5 not giving the thief any
time to to have this bishop c6 move and
it looks like he's going for some
exchange of the pawns or if the e pawn
gets traded C they do capture on d5 and
then Bishop e6 white is not left with a
very well defended passed pawn on e5 and
this could lead to some potential King
pawn endings if we imagine all the minor
pieces got traded where white would be
the one probably playing for the win
with just about your pawn structure but
black is also chances to to push kind of
on with the g5 and break the pawns there
and maybe we can do a pawn on e5 and we
cannot forget that black has a dead
advantage on the Queen side with one on
b7 and a six and the pawn can start
marching yeah we should not forget about
the Queen side majority for black it
doesn't look too scary at this point but
it is a long-term plan if black can
perhaps reorganize the pieces get some
better coordination these pawns
do out match the the lone pawn in e2
it's interesting to see that var is
thinking in this position because if you
move the bishop away from the diagonal
g8 a to the pollinator will be just
captured so one has to
to option he can take on e6 and it
changed the bishops all move back to b3
and apparently he may like the move
Bishop e3 - too many moved upon the
worldís Center from 80 to b3 after the
exchange that is a good point two
options for VAR and whenever you have
more than one option it is maybe a
decision moments where you have to
figure out what gives you the best
chances I
I think he's hesitant to capture the
bishop on e6 because it just gives black
time to improve the night where then
that would be very stable a great block
hater and putting constant pressure on
on white in this position but something
very similar could happen if he does
choose Bishop to b3 the bishops could
get traded the Knights still coming to
e6 so I do like the way of a thief is
kind of untangling here perhaps going
for the trade making it so after a trade
of minor pieces occurs the minor pieces
that he has left will actually be
effective in the position
yeah that's something you want to do if
you don't have an hour space you want to
trade and get some space for a thesis
now I see the trade happened Bishop
takes c6 Knight takes c6 and var just
responded with g3 g3 stabilizing move
making sure
pretty much everything on the kingside
is defended but now it's a question
which player is playing for the
advantage here it seems relatively equal
we haven't pointed this out but we do
have an endgame bishops of the same
color and look at White's King side
pawns all of them fixed on dark squares
for the time being so this could
potentially favor black and in the long
term if if any pawns become weak for
whites and black played King f7 I like
that move because it's time I be to
bring the King to the center bring the
King to the game and then decide whether
weak like Bishop e7 and g5 to crush
their or start marching with the pawns
on the Queen side now of course like I
tell my younger students that when you
when you reach an endgame your king
wants to be an active player you don't
always want to keep your King super-safe
especially in the endgame where you can
use it as a tool so both players
bringing their Kings closer to the
center we just see King d3
played and now Bishop to b4 by the sieve
what to do nuts for Varco bein so what
can I do I mean I might expect some idea
like King to c4 but with this last move
Bishop to b4 it seems like the Seif is
pondering the potential of Bishop v1 in
the position attacking from the rear and
this might be a bit unpleasant for for
the white site to meet and also it's
interesting that even if you reach King
c4 it's very hard to see how white King
can get near the black pawns because the
bishop and the knight the black pieces
are cooperating well and creating like a
wall yeah that doesn't seem like there's
any entry point currently for the White
King but sometimes it's just about
optimizing the position of the king and
then using the minor pieces to work
together so I'm sure a version wouldn't
be too disappointed if he could get his
King to d5 and then perhaps trying to
improve the knight and Bishop even
further
I wonder if white can play g4 I mean I
don't like to make the weakness on h4
but I do need to progress I need to
advance the pond somewhere to to improve
my position so what if I play g4 here g4
it seems weakening I think he doesn't
want to play it if it's not necessary we
do have a move played Bishop to d2 and
then very quickly from the sea if Knight
c5 check putting the question to the
white king the king is currently tied
down to the bishop on d2 so there aren't
too many options here and suddenly I
mean black and may be traded to the
bishops afterwards and advance the King
to 65 although that's it's not necessary
I mean my black Bishop is is active and
I can just move it to a three but it can
be an idea because every time we can
control the center with the King it's
good for the side that they that can
have the King in the center I do like
that plan let's imagine some move like
king c2 Trey the bishops on d2 kini six
box King is guaranteed to come to d5
where White's King would be a bit a bit
restricted and
then maybe black can start thinking
about the queenside advance and maybe
the thief has some chances here if he
can get the more active King and get his
Queen Cyclones ruling while White's
appears to have a hard time making
progress on the Kings side and it look
like it looks like the variation is
happening they traded Bishop by say
flight immediately King e6 and I think I
feel even if we just look at the clock
we see far having only two and a half
minutes the sea having seven minutes I
mean this tells you something about
what's happening on the board white is
probably not pleased with this position
and he tries to think hard to to find
the best variation Avar can't be too
comfortable here a huge time advantage
for a thief this is a 10 minute game and
I know it's hard to transition from
playing classical games to playing a
rapid game we're so used to taking a lot
of time to kind of sort through your
decisions and now you just have to play
on pure instincts some more moves coming
out of pretty rapid pace after a king
III King to d5 and I have to imagine
maybe with perfect play white can hold
on but it just seems a lot more pleasant
for a receive given the time advantage
and given that he has a very clear plan
just advance the queenside pawns and
then white might be the one on there
under pressure
white would like to exchange in Knights
here possibly to play something like 93
but let's say if 93 happened just to
show the variation well we do have a
move 93 and then black ghost 94 and
actually attacking and improving his
night so far did not go for this
variation and if I replayed g4g for
using the move or using your idea from
previously trying to maybe create some
more progress on the Kings side I do
like this move because now it's a
question for black what to do with the
pawn tension if the pawns got traded on
g4 the knight can come into play and
then there's some annoying Night Moves
ideas like nine oh six so I see the safe
to not take on g4 you went for h5h rough
is an interesting move you just want to
block it and make sure that maybe there
can be a bank where
White has to make a move and this helps
me to either improve my knight or
improve my king
you know what move I would be
considering here it looks a bit ugly but
I would love to get the knight attacking
the pawn in each five I'm pondering the
potential Knight each one but maybe
that's just bad before and then
each one is completely dominated so okay
93 was played allowing the potential for
a king point ending now it's a question
does Massif avoid the trade of knights
or should he go for the trade he should
probably avoid it yeah if he trades the
Knights we have to keep in mind that the
pawn on e5 is defended it's a passed
pawn it's very strong and black would
have to keep his king near the pond and
that would not allow him to win the game
so 96 was played seems like a very
reasonable move such a great block hater
on e6 making sure White's can't make
further progress on on the Kings side
and meanwhile I mean the sieve can keep
in mind ideas like neither fate and
Knight g6 where both of whites pawns
need some defenders in the position
because they're both potential
weaknesses I'm a little surprised to see
96 I expected
94 immediately to place the knight in
the center but 96 has a very 96 has a
very nice idea as you mentioned to go to
f8 + g6 and attack the pawns right and
we should also keep in mind black still
has the same idea I mean though the
pawns haven't moved much on the Queen
side yet but I I guarantee you at some
point to see if it's going to start
advancing these Queen side pawns and
enlarge should be the one on your
pressure we have one more move played
Knight - f2 so we can have a pair we can
have a repetition here if passive goes
95 mm-hmm and if our decides to go back
playing for the win
on d5 I told you these funds are gonna
get rolling very soon I mean absolutely
White is the one who is not having a
pleasant situation only one minute left
on clock there is no reason for a for
black to go for a bit we just saw nine
h1 moves are coming very rapidly let me
try and catch up here d4 Knight g3 97 so
far did go for your idea of it
Knight H 193 to attack the pawns but vas
if is probably happy that his pawns on
the queenside are advanced and the night
on g3 it is attacking the pawns but the
night the Black Knight is defending them
so it's okay yeah and after a five vara
is again under pressure I like the the
square that the C found for the knight
on g7 making sure the pawns are defended
and white isn't getting any counter play
and meanwhile okay the plan is very
simple for black just keep pushing pawns
and we might see a situation where
White's king will have to retreat and
maybe boxing can penetrate the position
so horribly has about 20 seconds to make
his next movement so virus retreating
with his knight Knight if one may be
trying to go to e3 and Italia king and
the pawn on f5 vassilis five minutes
there's a lot of time to think what to
what you didn't do in this situation so
do we expect a 4 a 4 just played and we
have to keep in mind that there's only a
2 second delay which is not much time at
all for our two to deal with in this
position 93 back playing with da is very
difficult because you really don't get
extra time the time it's only running
running off I remember playing and a
game like this it's just so stressful
because you never get a break you can
make extra move to game time exactly I
mean I I hate playing in these
situations when you're only 2 second
delay that's that's not much time at all
and especially being used to the
30-second increments it's a completely
different scenario but it's still a
question how is Wasif breaking through
here bar has 17 seconds so maybe the
thief just wants to put the pressure on
bar find some moves to force far to make
some decisions because let's say bossy
place king c5 var can go for something
like ethics just forcing tonight to
capture the pawn on e6 and then
capturing the pawn on H is exactly what
Farah was just some simplification in
the position and just try and hold on
for dear life draw the scheme and move
on to next game the sea is still
thinking here
time just falling below four minutes but
what other moved to play other than king
c5 seems like black might be running out
of options here
I think about a very nice idea of
playing a3 with black and let's say you
play Knight h1 the worst move in the
position I have a nice try with a three
this is a classic breakthrough idea
absolutely and now if white takes the
pawn the black pawn is going to a 2 and
just promoting into a queen so I'm sure
maybe if they see if considering this
potential idea with a3 actually makes
some sense in the position it's just a
matter ok white probably won't play
tonight eh 1 there may be you likely
play a move like King to c2 and it's
it's hard to calculate all the the lines
under time pressure but we're seeing
this line being played out a3 king c2
king c4 we might just have to look on
the board to see what's going on we do
see var went for this line with a 6 and
after 1986 and I take age 5 its deceased
move Knight d4 being played now it's a
question can black actually crash
through on the Queen side b3 it looks
like he's going there is a checkmate
because if he takes the pawn King takes
there our assumption yes wait does not
want the King to come in to b3 but
meanwhile how do you make progress as
black in this position can you play
something like B - yeah but you did play
and now trying to transfer the Knight to
c3 to check the King and promote I mean
I'd be fine
beautiful play by by black but is it is
there a breakthrough can I mean Knight
b5 can be met with 92 so what do we
start with King d3 now that's a pawn
right so King D 3 8 6 9 I'd be 5 and the
seat has about two and a half minutes on
the clock
var is down to 7 seconds so the thief
does have enough time to calculate this
position but he doesn't want to take any
risks I see my person succeed King XIII
yeah what to do after King g3 though
maybe he can see them board now let's
get to the current position oh he plays
might be 5 immediately for
in 92 and now king d threes some more
idea but it looks just about over after
95 92 King D 3 it seems like wise
philosopher goes for the handshake we
see handshakes evasive wins the first
game with black pieces I mean he pushed
a nice nice and game that was incredible
play for embassy if he played quickly
enough to to stay up on time really put
the pressure on bar it's not easy to win
these games with the black pieces
especially given given the resulting
middle game position it seemed like
White was the one playing for a win but
perhaps far over pushed maybe
underestimated the safes resources and
now now it's a question can conveyor
come back with the black pieces and
sometimes the interesting part for black
is you are black you just want to trade
pieces get into a draw and sometimes
that's a good strategy because you don't
think about win and it's white who has
the pressure to to try to figure out the
best moves in the positions that's right
and I'm being told the next round starts
at 4:30 central times we have 9 minutes
until the next round
maybe var maybe both players can cool
down after the the pretty intense time
scramble there and try and regroup and
especially for var he needs to he needs
to play for a win with the black pieces
not an easy task so we can just get the
graphics to see we have 2 players
playing playoff the first round receive
Dhirubhai Lee won again Farah Cobian and
the second round
vasee is gonna be white that's right and
the see if all he needs to do is draw I
know he's an e4 player so maybe we can
expect some some may be quiet before
opening and now that's a question what
does a KO beam and choose again c4 I
don't think he's a Sicilian player I
know he's played the French but if he
plays a French that could just walk into
exchange variation so any opening
predictions for revoir I'm just curious
to see if we're gonna save a save as we
know him aggressive attacking or if
that's gonna be a solid one who is
trying just to you know keep the draw
and just finish it off in the second
round that's actually a really good
point I think if you're in this
situation why not just play your style
do what you've been doing don't change
anything
to drastically even though a draw does
clinch that the the title and the money
you should probably go for his style if
art plays something maybe like a modern
or appearance I wouldn't be surprised if
he plays some aggressive line just going
for another win yes so we have exciting
game and var has to push for win I mean
here's he's losing zero to one and he
has to make a win in order to go to the
Armageddon so maybe we can review the
playoff format yeah we can take a look
at the playoff format we do have one
rapid game finished which means if the
sieve wins or draws next rapid game
tournament is over if a thief will be
the winner of Group A if far does
managed to win with the black pieces it
will go to Armageddon and anything can
happen from there and based on this game
I think my save would be okay taking
back I mean he has time he never has
problems with time and there were
chances for draw so you want to make
sure you are black if there are changes
chances for draw absolutely but we're
going to take a very quick break and
we'll be back with the second rapid game
in Group A so stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone we are here in the
studio we are having the second round of
the playoff VAR is starting good game
soon and he has to push for a win it's
right not easy psychological situation
to be in having the black pieces and
he's faced probably the hottest player
of the tournament to see if Jerry Bailey
who's who's played an amazing event
winning so many games maybe had a slow
finish but the Seif played excellent
chess in the first rapid game as we saw
winning with the black pieces so now the
Cephas White's I'm sure the game is
going to be started any second now I
mean we can expect a very fighting game
or we can expect a very boring opening
from massive what do you think is gonna
happen I mean I think var is gonna be
the one who needs to steer the game into
more exciting waters I was just looking
up his opening stats on I'm just
Gamescom and I'm expecting a perk let's
see what happens
d6 maybe or g6 so what same is starting
with e4 no d4 no name thought and now
it's larger to decide the fact that he's
thinking maybe didn't decide before
French we have French here well we see
an exchange variation oh wow so we will
see a boring opening how do you play for
a win in the French exchange with the
black side not going to be an easy task
I was actually looking at some of the
variations were black and try to play
with long side castle and try to push
for a win but it's I mean this is a
situation you don't want to have when
you are black I'm I'm kind of surprised
that var1 for this variation I'm very
surprised too but we'll have to see if
he has any ideas in mind I do like the
fact to see if not going for any really
sharp French lines given var is as well
prepared in those and the current
position Bishop d3 c5 okay the first
maybe imbalancing move maybe trying to
go for some isolate means pawn position
or black might have more activity this
is probably the way to play if black
wants to go for for any sort of
dynamically
position absolutely getting an isolated
bone and trying to play for some some
attack with the bishops having squares
to go to what is the Steve gonna do is
he's gonna take or probably he's gonna
play something like c3 just to make sure
we don't open it too much I mean c3 aims
to keep the symmetry if c3 is played the
pawns got traded still very symmetrical
position hard to revive for black to
push for much I mean I wouldn't mind
here as white maybe just going for the
trade on c5 I like playing against the
IQ P and a position like this where
White has already some very nice
development among the bishops seems like
this week necessarily be a bad option
for whites it looks like vastus is
thinking hard and I don't remember
thinking him too hard during the first
game and so this is a tough situation
for him he's thinking do I go for an
open position or do I just block it with
c3 that's right but surprise he's taking
so much time here but I mean maybe the
first moment where he's out of his his
opening preparation I'm sure he doesn't
play the exchanged French too often with
the white pieces maybe this is his first
time playing the exchange French so he's
probably not familiar with this exact
position he does go for c3 probably just
the most solid move in the position of
art quickly responds with 96 I think
from bars perspective he wants to put
the pressure on early try and make this
you think because if you can't win in
the position maybe you can get your
opponent low on time and then try and
provoke some laundry later on we have a
very logical move Knight f3 what just
wants to people of the Knights Castle a
very harmonious development for whites I
mean this is uh this is a setup I would
love to show my students just all of
White's pieces coming to life in a very
harmonious manner and okay
Farah responds Bishop to g4 putting some
pressure on the night maybe trying to to
later take on d4 and put even more
pressure on the paint piece but what is
gonna Y do maybe Bishop e2 Castle
that's a question can white actually
gather way with leaving the d4 pawn
hanging I mean the move you would like
to play here is why this is just a
simply castle and it's a question after
a pawn take on d4 can might actually
play pawn to d4 or maybe I move like
Queenie one check and then go for Knight
takes e4 I think we're safe style is
just to take on d4 and even sacrifice
the pawn because the black King still
has not castle so we see Vasilis going
for the castle and even for the
sacrifice but var is not taking the pawn
because it can be a very poison point to
go for instead he is developing the
bishop and going for for castle just to
make sure the king is safe and trying to
maybe capture the pawn later yeah I am
curious what the exact reason was for
not capturing the pawn on d4 maybe it
would be something like Queen a4 check
knight c6 rook e1 where light is getting
a lot of active play very quickly
following with Knight e5 I mean those
pieces are amazing yes a probably good
decision by vara not to capture on d4
but rather complete development after a
Bishop e7 it was receive he played
Knight BD to brings us to the current
position which seems it seems very solid
for white and that's what the chief
wants in this game and now maybe virus
thinking maybe now I can take on d4
because at least the rook with even it's
not a chair because the bishop is there
on e7 because if black does not take the
pawn right now and let's say decides to
castle white can go h3 attack the bishop
so let's say castle h3 we are attacking
the bishop and suddenly why this maybe
not having the best situation because I
can move my queen away from the pin at
any moment and white is very happy with
the setup actually like quite far has or
of a thief has done psychologically here
he's put far in a situation where now
vara needs to decide it's a critical
moment
do you take the pawn and maybe go for
some very risky position or play it safe
and castle he does go for castling he
took about a minute on that move of a
seat plate h3 very quickly and Bishop h5
played so now it's it's a line that we
just saw that you were mentioning
probably we can expect to move here like
Queen B 3 Queen b3 or queen 84 I'm not
sure where I want to put the Queen but
definitely out of the pain just
connecting the rooks
and threatening something like 95 I mean
the night to go to a perfect center then
connect the rooks put them on file I
don't see any issue for a white here and
this seems like exactly the position the
chief is happy with a symmetrical
structure with like a small edge for
white given more activity especially
with the Queen on b3 putting constant
pressure on the pawns on d5 and b7 also
995 potential idea later on in the
position we see Knight a5 played
interesting move my bar hitting the
Queen defending the b7 pawn now it's the
question where does white move the Queen
probably Queen 84 I've seen the sieve
doing this many times he reaches out his
hand hovering over the board then goes
back to the thinking pose maybe wants to
take some more time here but maybe not
Queen a4 it was played and a6 played
very quickly by var so this is this
reminds me of some of like some of these
exchange swap positions where the
structure is so symmetrical and this is
a very typical idea from black to say go
for this Queen side expansion I'm sure
of our wants to play pawn b5 get the
Knight to c4 and maybe there's something
to play for maybe the this these Queen
moves by a thief aren't achieving too
much I see one more move has been played
rook AC 1 normal-looking move putting
the rook on the very open C file and I
wouldn't be surprised if if R goes for
this this b5 expansion here I feel like
you start with a6 that's the first step
you have to follow up with the second
step and then I don't see 4 is very
strong really you mentioned it's
attacking the knight it's it's attacking
upon its getting some some activity over
over the squares and then I can even
develop finis develop and with rook a c8
I think far has to go would be 5 but he
is taking some time here so maybe
there's something that he's not entirely
comfortable with in the position if we
speculate and say black plays b5 I would
expect whites Queen to
perhaps drop back to c2 and then if we
imagine Knight c4 maybe if a thief is
just fine just ignoring the knight on c4
and going for a play of his own with a
move like 95 there's definitely a
possibility now probably like black
would play with rook c8 just finishing
the development and we see maybe
somewhat more exciting position compared
to what we had in the opening this is
exchange French where the position does
eventually become a bit more imbalanced
some very quick moves played there after
b5 Queen c2 played instantly and then
Knight c4 played instantly so we do have
this current position at 95 plays so I
was I was predicting the future there
are those so now we need to var to play
rook c8 to finish our variation but we
do have to know that vasee if it's okay
with drawing this game that's enough for
him to win the playoff so far has to
create some complications and try to try
to get an advantage try to trick versiv
into a bad variations where he can maybe
get advantage so Queen b6 no rooks ea6
pressuring the d4 pawn and instantly
played Knight df3
reinforcing the pawn in d4 I like this
move a lot because not only does it
reinforce a pawn but it may be prepared
a very simple pawn b3 chasing away the
knight from c4 we have one more move
played rook a to C AIT's pressuring the
Queen along the C file perhaps we could
expect something like Queen e2 or queen
b1 in this position Queen B 1 was played
I mean this is a position that you want
to have with white you have no issues
you have active pieces you have even
some threads on h7 I mean there is the
battery that's very strong and you can
draw this position drawing is fine for
you so I think it's a very pleasant
situation for Wasif exactly but we have
to keep in mind there there's a lot of
tension in the position all the minor
pieces still on the board even though
the pawn structure is relatively
symmetrical there could be some
complications happening Bishop d6
followed by Bishop f5 looks like the
thief is trying to optimize his position
trying to make out o bishop take f3 was
played wow going for the the
counter-attack ignoring the work on c8
things are about to get very tactical I
mean that's something you need to do is
black you want to complicate stuff but I
mean is that enough I'm just taking a
rogue what's happening there should be
for a very nice move by VAR hitting the
Queen on b1 the thief leaning back and
shaking his head he can't be happy it
looks like you just missed the simple
simple shot Bishop b4 and now the queen
is forced to a one I'm expecting var to
recapture but maybe it's not so simple
if R takes the bishop on c8 there is b3
present in the position maybe just lassi
was tricking and showing that he missed
the Bishop e7 but actually he's doing
very fine out honey can't you trust your
opponent's reactions we saw the leaning
back and head shake usually means that
you're in trouble but maybe it means
that he can't believe that this
variation is actually working for him
var is now thinking because rook takes
c8 just runs into the simple pawn b3
black would love to retreat the Knight
to d6 or d6 but both of those four is
off-limits and it's a thief going to be
the one of material interesting
variation is here Queen takes d4 but
this did not not happen but I just took
rook takes c8 and now Knight h5 played
very quickly by bar the variation
continues these are the types of
positions which just make my head hurts
so many things like hanging and being
attacked and so many trades the current
material situation black does have if
I'm countering correctly two minor
pieces for a rook and it's just a
question can white win back some
material along the C file is Bishop on
that for currently hanging and white can
go for some traits like Knight takes e4
pawn takes e4 I take c4 which pawn takes
c4 because let's say we take Bishop
takes d6 Quinte d6 do have exchange up
but now let's look at the case actually
it's not exchanged up there's two minor
pieces for four
in this case so that's easy to lose
track of the material situation and
secondly just the pieces are there
attacking the King so that's not a good
situation
oh look at this move by the thief pawn
takes c4 cold-blooded leaving the bishop
available for capture but then he goes
for Plan C five with the fork in the
position looks like the thief just
managed to calculate this out and it
seems like he's going to be out material
after after he wins this bishop on g6
but still I mean if we look at the
knight and the bishop they are still
attacking the King there are gonna be
some problems I think white man I mean
black may take the pawn on c5 just
Bishop takes e5 it should take c5 pawn
takes e5 it's very important that y can
keep the initiative and not allow that
to capture the hanging partner g2 so if
I go now Queen f6 just maybe Queen 8c
experiment just trying to put some
pressure on the King side it seems like
vara is gonna have to go for a line like
this where where he is down material but
going for the King side attack but is it
enough I mean white can probably respond
with them moves like Knight g4 but you
have to be careful there's an
interesting variation let's say now I go
Knight eat you and if you miss then you
went to king h1 I have a very strong
move Queen take h3 so probably king h2
here very complex now I have Queen f4
Mina for g3 Queen f3 3 but then maybe 93
we could play on and on and on there are
some interesting I mean what has to be
careful but yeah let's revert to the
current position var is taking his time
trying to figure out which line gives
him the best chances we did not see pawn
takes e5 we say we see rook takes e5
then everything getting traded on c5 so
white is up the exchange for two pawns
in this position so there's actually
material equality if if we just rely
purely on the the point system I'm just
not surprised as black went to trader
rooks because the rooks on c1 I thought
there is a potential to get it back by
some force with not a t2 but okay we
have these trades Black has two pawns
and a bishop for a rook
right and the thief would love to play
this move rook c1 going for some back
rank ideas against the black king but
rook c1 just simply runs into 92
not to mention Queen takes e1 followed
by 92
so the RIC can't yet get to the open
file and now it's a question what to do
for whites Missy if is going for
counter-attack 97 leaving the g2 pawn
still hanging but attacking the Queen on
c5 I'm just a bit suspicious of this 997
I mean what if our play is a simple
Queen d6 here there would be multiple
things attacked in the position but
maybe black I mean white goes only to
simplified position so let's say you
play Queen d6 I want to simplify so I go
Queenie 5 just to trade and I mean I
want to draw that's true but black is
winning a bunch of pawns bishop take
your Bishop take G 2 might be possible
and then rook c1 could be met with
Bishop take h3 guarding the c8 square
yes but the rook is finally free to go
somewhere so maybe if we go inside of
rooks you wanna route d1 still Bishop
take h3 barbar is winning a lot of pawns
in the sign somehow I feel that ok let
me go rook e1 rook you want this to take
h3 and now I am threatening some
checkmate on the back rank so I can be
tricky and play maybe 93 93 but then 96
I think about night c5 the black should
have everything under control let's go
back to the current position and that's
what's happening
Queen d6 Queen e5 we have here Trading
Queens we do not see the plan being
captured on g2 rather Laura went for
this advanced pawn d4 Wow and now it's
all about simplifying the position all
the CFS to do try and trade things off
don't let black when too many pawns the
ponies utterly dangerous I mean d4 d3
supported by 9 supported by bishop oh
it's a scary position for whites and
times taking down for the thief I would
be inclined just to play a move like
rook t1 here I just put the rook
facing the D pawn and then if I move
like d3 is play just a very simple chief
to try and chase the night away so you
can win a pawn in d3 but I think it's
maybe after all do you wanna I do tell
you to fall on g2 now rook t1 t2 rook t1
was played
so if bishop take g2o rook takes e4
you're thinking 92 mm-hmm we could play
this out real quick just to show the
viewers after this exchange black would
be up to pawns in the final position so
probably a very favorable line for black
so far is that okay he's not taking the
pawn on g2 he's pushing the night away
from the center and maybe then allowing
to play d3 and half maybe more chances
there I really like this move f65 are
not only gaining tempo on the Knights
but avoiding any sort of battering the
possibilities and enabling the king just
to come in very very quickly along the
diagonal and if our can get his King to
a square like e6000 be more support for
the pawn on d4 and it seems like the
thief is nervous kind of fidgeting
around there we players have only two
minutes last two minutes there's delay
there's no increment very stressful
situation you can see the the stress and
Asif's motions are after ninety seven of
our finally captures pawn on g2 now
white is down three pawns for the
exchange and what to do is white king h2
played d3 bar continues to make progress
the sea is still under pressure so the
Vigo King t3 now hitting the night and
if the knight goes away we can change
the future might be met with g5 but then
f6 would hang but King to three g5 9 xf
6 with Chuck I think that was a very
crucial pawn that far just lost but I
mean White's King is a bit precarious on
g3
oh the see if is continuing pawn
grabbing knight take h7 King g6
play is unfolding very rapidly var going
for that King activity and lights Knight
being a bit misplaced on f8
but it's a question of whether black can
continue to make progress with the minor
piece of supporting this despawned III
so I'm very still here refreshing the
side I'm not like I think they move that
at some point we'll probably just have
to take a look at the the video of the
board this play plays continuing to
unfold after ninety seven Missy ferry
simply wants to bring the knight back to
c5 hitting the pawn in d3 maybe going
after the plum in e6 and I mean it's all
a question how does of our actually make
progress here and I think the c f-- is
in a good situation given that all he
needs to do is not let black make too
much progress and he should at least
draw the game and at one moment I can't
even take with rook on d3 and when the
knight recaptures I can recapture the
bishop so white is doing fine suddenly
so a bishop d5 played and then Knight c5
simply targeting the claw in d3 I think
we can expect something like Bishop to
c4 this is VARs last hope just this pawn
on d3 not caring about this pawn in a6
he has to go all-in here to to try and
create some last winning chances I mean
it's gonna take the last one yes so he
was 52 can I take 86 var2 gonna a to
actually that maybe it wasn't a bad
trade for far after the a plans come off
the board for now has an additional
passed pawn on d5 and maybe the plan is
to bring the bishop back to c4 so I
wonder if I go night before here night
before was played in Bishop c4 and then
King Geoffrey just bring the Queen sir
what's being played with a simple threat
of King III and White has a nice
blockade here making sure that blacks
pawns can advance further pawns being
stuck on on b5 and t3 and long scheme
can't really be improved
yeah the difficulties for black to see
how to advance because all your pawns
are blocked with the king it's very hard
to find a way how to how to break in and
you can recapture with knight on h3
because then you lose control of the d3
square of the d3 pawn
yeah h3 pawn is not too relevant in this
position given the knight is tied down
to this pawn indeed
and var is thinking as time is ticking
down king e5 played very simple King III
5 a thief I'm wondering maybe a move
like Knight G to check followed by king
d4 but doesn't seem like these lines
were working out for a black I feel
every time 6 King DC is he going for
King c5 but this does allow white to
play King to d4 just get some activity
with the King and then IDF in week after
King d6 to push the pawn maybe h4
because the knight is no longer defended
by the king h4 was that [ __ ] potential
move in position but King g4 played I
mean why not further improve the king
and vark going back with this King to e6
it seems like the Seif is actually the
one maybe making some some progress here
we see King III back now King f6 perhaps
bar is looking to try and come around to
the King side maybe this is the last
hope in the position to come through via
g6 h5 and go after the h3 pawn
I wonder if white can play h4 now h4
potentially be no reason kingi for
improving the King
Oh 19 h3 that was kind of a messy move
uh-huh tricky move because now you can
now take on d3 was King me for just a
blunder a honkey III back so the h3 pawn
has vanished from the position hard to
keep up here let's just focus on the
video of a thief's move yeah I think you
blundered the H pawn but Elias rook is
getting active in the position that's a
good part so the rook is behind now I'm
gonna be checking the King but what's
the time on the clock oh there's it
seems like about 7 seconds for receive
about 15 seconds for VAR not much time
left for either side it's going to be a
pretty intense time scramble see both
players
shuffling around the pieces sometimes
plate can get messy in these these later
stages of the time scramble I have
information that Vasily is only four
seconds and remember tear
two-second delay no increment I mean
vassal is getting nervous you can see it
how he's insecure with his moves
King f3 Bacchus seems to be making
progress the King doesn't want to
penetrate the position f2 is the next
weakness for for Bach to attack and now
the knight maneuvering probably to f3
and the thief's hope
oh the Seif one the d3 pawn to e3 pawn
was crucial I think Farah plundered
that's a huge simplification oh do we
have a controversy looks like the Seif
pause the clock and now it won't be rich
unseen it looks like the king is checked
by dog and by denied so it's it's
impossible to have such double check so
probably of our made an illegal move
Knight Jiwon that's what seems that
vassal is arguing for I mean I missed it
I'm not sure if we have a slow-motion
replay I know they were using
slow-motion replays on st. Louis Robin
blitz last year being told we don't have
a slow-motion replay but I'm sure the
viewers can probably go back look at the
YouTube live stream and and see what
happened I wonder if Tony riches is
doing just that we can see Tony rich and
Mike comer in the corner they're both
players still at the board what do you
think the call is here I think it's just
the illegal move that Vasa fees arguing
for but I think the city is getting a
break now and even if the claim goes to
him or not he's having I think a winning
position right now because of the
three-point was a crucial point and now
it seems that he should not have an
issue with withholding this position
okay I'm being told Katerina you are
right about the speculation arbor is
trying to work out the situation
maybe consulting the video replay I do
have the the PGN moves of the position
but probably we should stay with the
video and see what's going on here
looks like the thief nodding his head I
am curious does an illegal move end the
game in a rapid format or it just time
get added to the clock
I am not sure but I think that since
even in a classical game two moves to
illegal moves to lose the game I believe
one illegal move should be enough to
lose a rapid game no it looks like he
added time look at the clock it's it's
chose two minutes four for the white
player of a thief so probably he was
correct with this claim of the legal
move not a great situation for our
losing the pawn on d3 and now having a
serious time deficit with just probably
a simple conversion for a thief I mean
if I Steve now has two minutes that's
such a huge time advantage what I got I
mean Tony rich coming back to the board
seems like the players are confused it
looks like they're analyzing the
position trying to figure out pointing
to the f8 square I believe the last move
that black made Liga was Knight G 1 so
the knight should go back to f3 and vari
supposed yes I think this is the correct
position and now it's blacks turn yeah
this is usually the right call when
there's an illegal move played you have
to go back to the last known legal
position which probably is this moment
and now the C if having two minutes to
think not sure if we were going to have
the PGN or the board because it is
showing a PG and error given that's
illegal bootless played Tony rich back
at the board for a third time just more
confusion going on I don't know what it
looks like it said Tony rage is pointing
out like let's article guys let's let's
play can only speculate at this point
maybe 20 wants to flavor seats next move
is getting help from the actual video
they're gonna watch it to see what's
happening both of the monitor not sure
if we have a better angle a bit
difficult to see what's going on there
but maybe both players consulting the
video replay here there's the angle do
you have so they are looking at the game
Tony rich is explaining what happened it
seems the players understood they are
going back VAR is going back last save
Darren sitting next to board and the
clock is going to start have you ever
seen something like this I mean this is
uh this is pretty unusual for players to
go back and forth like that but plate is
continuing the game is going on so
capturing the pieces very hard shot at
this point
Mike comer blocking one of the camera
angles there may be keeping a closer eye
given what just happened but hands are
shakin looks like looks like the thief
has won the game given that bar was in a
must-win situation you know what this
means
the thief is the champion for Group A I
mean if I see that excellent tournament
he won the first round in the playoff he
drew the second one and he is winner of
the group a know very impressive play by
to see if especially in the rapid game
today I did not know that in exchange
French could be this exciting I mean if
we if we look at or if we saw the
opening I mean it seemed very
symmetrical very boring but things got
very tactical in that middle game I feel
it's always exciting to watch a game
where there is delay and no increment
because players really can go out of the
trouble of having no time they have to
keep being stressed and being making
quick moves I mean and this is what can
happen you can make your league move
yeah we see the Chiefs teammate there
Peter Piroska giving a handshake the see
Finbar shaking hands yet again and now
they're analyzing the position but
before we we go into that
congratulations massif dora bailey from
azerbaijan clinching the $6,000
first-place prize for group a he got got
off to an incredibly fiery start winning
the first four games not having the the
strongest finish
but pulling through in a rapid playoff
against revision podium and we had him
here in the studio and he was saying I'm
just finishing my finals doing my last
projects
he finished his school he wins the
tournament wouldn't amazing start for
your vacation yeah and they're still
analyzing the game very impressive that
after such a long and enduring
tournament like this you're just
inclined to analyze some more chess yeah
congratulation
I see durable a very nice tournament and
very good play we have to say for VAR he
had a great tournament as well
playoff didn't work well maybe the first
game was very difficult and then it's
very hard to push for win when you are
black that's true and we should I should
note that far with your pick to win the
tournament in Group A so you were you
were so close but but no cigar for you
the seif pulling through in the end
hopefully we can get them in the studio
I think it's just a matter of him
cooling down he probably knows where he
needs to go at this point and yeah
walking there maybe returning his pen
and I'm sure he'll he'll be downstairs
in no time so it looks like we're gonna
take just a very short break we will get
back safe to the studio and we will talk
with him about how it is to win such a
tournament
[Music]
a question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that there
was a bit of a champion for those of you
who are new to chess it might look like
ba 3 is an illegal move here because
white masters pawn to square is not one
but it still is something we call all
pass on and you can do that but you have
to do it instantly you can't wait for a
move
I played sake play King in seven kimchi
- and I'll try because y'all play four
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed at length during the course of
my stay
yeah he told me this is excellent g5
this was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think the farthest I know
who Lawrence this is not how chess works
certainly would be much much more
furniture such to work like this I don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me and what's worse I
will never hear the end of it my quality
of life has just gone downhill
tremendously because I'm actually
sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back in the
studio and women grandmaster catherine
EMTALA and i'm joined here by the winner
of group a tournament massive durable a
congratulations thank you very much
so can you just tell us what happened
what was the controversy at the
beginning here at the end of the game he
made an illegal move here instead of I
mean playing with king or taking my
knight he played here
Knight g1 and I realized that he made it
illegal move after Luke f8 so you played
okay fight that happened right yeah and
as far as I know according to Federal
Rules arbiter shouldn't intervene in
this kind of cases and stop the game but
I think an arbiter also mr. illegal move
so I stopped and according to the rules
we started playing from the beat from
that position yes so we saw Tony rich
coming back and forth you guys going to
the computer did you go to watch the
video or what did you do there are we
check the moves to make sure that we are
going to play from right positions but
if I was very agree that he made an
illegal move yes yeah so this was a very
tough game can you just walk us through
what was the critical situation well I
mean he started it's a exchanged French
such a boring choice openings yeah I've
been I've never played exchanged French
because my style is kind of I'm playing
overthrowing well I told I won the first
game and Andrew is okay then somehow I
got bad position I mean I'm not sure
about that but I have I had some
problems maybe I should have taken D
takes e5 but instead I played castle
tactic night deterrent here our Korean
didn't take 94 amazing in this studio
and we thought it you have some contra
playing maybe with Queen a4
yeah it's 95 Bishop d7 I was thinking
maybe I will
some concerns I believe like what do you
think it was got a chance for black to
go for first we thought that this is a
critical situation because after Castle
it seems that after h3 you are doing
okay yeah I think why this is slightly
better and here I was really happy about
my position I did not understand why he
played Bishop d6 and first I was like
what's the idea that I completely missed
that he wants to take this away three
there was a very strong trick I mean we
did not anticipate it as well to just go
here
I wonder what's happening after b3 here
I should I should have played b3 so this
we were attacking then I mean if
actually he can still take Bishop f3 so
he takes D take C maybe this position is
bad for me we have some trees yeah yeah
so he said the b3 probably here the best
one was like Bishop g3 or h2 now what's
the idea the idea when he takes f3 I can
take with night probably Bishop h2 so
one new gold here so after taking just
feeling free just to take that three so
okay so you want with Bishop f5
attacking the rook on FA yeah everything
is fine I heard he wants something event
he took I was like I'm completely lost
then then I saw that oh you cannot play
midnight because see it is hanging so
was there a little luck yeah actually
there without like winning the
tournament is really hard so 95 happened
you took and there were some crazy
trades we kind of thought that maybe
it's may better not to try the rocks
here for white for for black
well I mean if he doesn't take well I'm
going to play something like Roxy six
and you don't have a so captures you
know were discussing that they should
have taken the pawns Bishop g2 inside of
the before yes we should have been
better I mean this is such a complicated
position to play you have less than two
minutes the bishop and nines are very
tricky pieces they can make Forks and I
mean you wonder I have one no I see
their idea is that if Bishop age three I
can channel somewhere like t3 knight c6
Knight before and I'm taking back so I
think that's even a variation we were
analyzing with Eric something like this
96 95 94 so I'm taking one poem back so
d for VAR was not very happy after
analysis you said to the group d1 look
Devon f6 and here I don't have any
problem I'm suddenly there were some
problems I did not when you play fast I
mean here I was happy about my position
and then here I was thinking that I
should play h4 probably I should have
done
damn I saw Knight G to king of three
night h4 end here after King e43 is
hanging I think that's kind of the
crucial pawn when the ponies record that
cannot defend but he said I decided
first I I will put my king on e4 damn
play h4 so there is no night g2 and then
i blundered of course 93
luckily the position is still equal and
we had a question so after this this
issue with the illegal move let's move
there here so you take so did var try to
play or he just said okay you have time
advantage you got extra two minutes
there he wanted to play by the he flag
we both had two seconds here and it's
not increment so it's really hard delay
that's why everything can happen even in
this level so it's interesting it
started as a French exchange friend but
happen to be a very interesting game a
lot of tactics so congratulations for
winning this tournament now I have
question you just finish your school you
just wanted to remind what are your next
plans how do you feel I need to move out
from my apartment so I'm going to pack
all my stuff I don't have much time
tomorrow morning I'm going to Chicago
open mm-hmm and then I will go home
spend some time with my family
I think I'm not sure that I will play
any chess tournament during this summer
so the next time if you have a Chicago
pandan you think you will take a break
enjoy your vacation actually be done
with school and so arguing back to your
family yes I'm going to abortion on May
29th well enjoy your vacation
congratulations very nice tournament
great games we enjoy doing commentary
for display of an enjoy your vacation
thank you so we'll be back after a very
short break
[Music]
[Music]
this August the best chess players in
the world are coming to st. Louis for
the grand chess tour
st. Louis rapid and Blitzen Sinquefield
Cup tournaments will feature the world's
best right here in st. Louis st. Louis
Chess Club is celebrating its 10th
anniversary and these tournaments will
be a highlight you won't want to miss
for tickets and more information go to
st. Louis chess club org
there's a weekend vacation on one tank
trip in a nearby city this is a crucial
situation in this game Metheny must make
a move but what will it be all eyes are
on methine make a move a lot easier if
you weren't doing that right next to me
it doesn't bother me check the st. Louis
chess club celebrating 10 years of
promoting teaching and playing the game
of chess visit the st. Louis chess club
and help celebrate our 10th anniversary
you
welcome back everyone we are here for
some final thoughts I am women great
master Catarina Mattila and I'm joined
back by international master Eric Rosen
good to be back and yeah we're gonna
wrap it up here let's take a look at the
final standings for Group B we had a
somewhat quieter finished compared to
Group A with Camille dragon winning the
tournament very impressive six and a
half out of nine points it talked with
Camille after he clinched victory and it
seemed like he wasn't expecting such an
incredible result but all congrats to
him and best of luck to him at the
Chicago open and second was Andre stuck
open and the third spot goes to
I just forgot I don't see the graphics
anymore but JJ ally Miranda and Roberta
Kazarian so moving on to standings in
Group A we had a very exciting rapid
playoff with received our Bailey winning
both rapid gains to edge out version of
Cobian to take the the title and the top
prize and Sam Savion finishing clear
third with five and half points so he
drew to David receive and that was
enough for him to to clinch the bronze
medal so congratulation to vasudevaya
Lee who is the winner for Group A and we
do want to note that there are some
exciting events coming up in in the near
future your next move
starts June 12th I believe it's the
first edition of the grand chest tour
and then of course in August we're gonna
have two more very exciting events
taking place in st. Louis with the st.
Louis rapid and blitz August 9th through
the 16th and then of course the CFL comp
as well so make sure to follow up the
broadcast for these amazing events and
with some incredible games strong
grandmasters I think it's gonna be very
exciting and I do want to say it's been
a pleasure for both of us doing
commentary throughout the event it was
our first time doing commentary lots to
learn but it was very enjoyable to see
so many exciting games and I think now
it's time to oh look a picture of us
that's a nice picture I think it's time
for maybe
bughouse maybe some unwinding some nice
dinner so so thank you so much for
following us listening to our commentary
I hope you'll learn and maybe see you
someday in future definitely see you see
you guys in the future shout out to
everyone watching around the world if
you want to review any of the games go
to us chess champs calm and hopefully
we'll be back sometime in the future
bye take care
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you